please be upstanding for the chairman of
the council
and aggression on a daily basis
we think of those who are suffering as a
result of natural disaster and we pray
that support would arrive where it is
needed
we remember those who are affected by
the war in Ukraine fighting that is
ongoing still after a year
we pray for leadership and for peace
as we think closer to home we are aware
of the leadership and power that we
wield in our local communities
and so we lift the members of this
Council to you the business of this
meeting
we pray for a productive meeting the
discussions will be effective and
decisions will be clear
we pray that important things will be
tackled and sensitivity over handling
delicate issues would be evident
give this Council solutions that best
meet the needs and benefits those that
they serve
in the name of Jesus Christ
amen
thank you members being seated thank you
welcome to this thought council meeting
and it will be quite a busy one there's
an awful lot on the agenda
um
I would appreciate it if we can be as
brief as if possible
I'm seeing a few rice miles there
but if we could please keep it brief
because there's quite a lot of business
to do today and thank you very much
indeed for that
right
moving into the agenda
add item one apologies for absence Mr
Buckland
thank you chairman apologies have been
received from councilors allcock Cleve
Harris Jennings parry and Richards
um councilor
fitter isn't with us at the moment but
it's expected to attend in the short
while the minutes will reflect what time
he joins us thank you
thank you
explosions of Interest members are there
any disclosures that you wish to make
I see no hands if there are any at the
rise during the meeting obviously please
just let me know at the appropriate time
and thank you very much indeed
uh minutes of meeting you all have the
minutes in front of you
are there any questions or queries on
the minutes
I will take that as a resounding no and
thank you very much indeed I shall sign
those off so
and oh sorry I do need a second for that
can I have a second before the minute
thank you Council cattle
are we all agreed
okay
announcements
um first I would just like to
make an announcement about a
previous member
of this Council a councilor Gordon
mucklow
he actually was a council way before I
was a I joined the council and I don't
think many people do do remember him at
all
however he served the council very very
well for his period of time
and again it shows the commitment to the
council over those years
um so I would just like to move the
following that this Council notes with
regret the death of former councilor
Gordon muklow and state extends its
sympathy to his family and friends in
their loss
I will agreed
thank you
okay
um go to announcements
and I'm going to just jump out of
sequence a little bit because I was I
heard on the news today that uh
the Speaker of the House of Commons
Betty boothroid sadly passed away today
uh and she was a snow wart she was an
amazing character
uh one of the original Tilly girls
so you know it shows you what you can do
in politics isn't it I understand that
Penny Ann would you like to say a couple
of words on this thank you
thank you chair it was really just to
recognize that the passing of baroness
boothroid who was that was an absolute
Trailblazer being the first female
Speaker of the House of Commons and for
those of us really interested in
standing for our local communities she
stood in West Bromwich West and it took
her five attempts to get her seat so
showing that gritty determination really
does get you there but she was a fine
example of someone who did courteous
collaborative cross-party working just
as we do here adhere to the Nolan
principles of life and I think just
shows that you can have a passion for
politics and make a huge difference and
she's described by all with such
fondness and I thank you for recognizing
the passing just a week before
International women's day
thank you
okay uh Liz are you or Howard is it
ready with these my
presentation
it's been a busy period uh over
Christmas we attended a number of
um Council um Council uh Civic services
and we've had a few uh Civic events
otherwise if you go to the next mile
please
uh that was an interesting one Council
cleave desperately wanted me to show you
this Photograph
we went to the goodwara in Warwick and I
must admit it was a fascinating day uh
very very hospitable people love the
love the the actual building itself
which is now quite a few years old but
it's it's in a stunning condition if you
go to the next slide please
and the inside is amazing and again if
you've never been in a good warrior then
and getting the opportunity I recommend
you do go and there's
but it's an amazing old place a
fantastic and lovely people and we were
entertained royally afterwards with a
with some uh some superb food which is
part of the Sikh culture next slide
please
uh we went to the RSC uh I went with
Kate that time and I thought it was a
very powerful performance very powerful
and it shows the quality of the RSC and
what the things they do put on there
some very acrobatic
um acting as well so very interesting
next slide please
then we went to the
um
coming up the name of the film place
this is an interesting one it was
folklore next slide please the HSA
folklore uh and also the the costumes
and touch light and it's fascinating
some of the things that that have gone
on over the years again if you have an
opportunity I do recommend going there
but it's really well worth seeing
next one please
we went to the the tattoo uh I'd say
International but it's certainly
National tattoo because it's got uh well
it just suppose it's European it had the
French German and uh British troops
marching marching bands and such like
and many many other volunteers from
around the around the the area I suppose
mostly in Birmingham a fascinating day
really really interesting and some
marvelous Precision marching which is uh
and I thoroughly enjoyed that next one
please
all right now for for all of you that
may or may not know I hope most of you
know the Greg Hall in Ulster uh
Stratford District Council took over the
hall a couple of years ago
they granted a 125-year lease to the
Town Council and we spent the last year
refurbishing it and spent over 400 000
pounds on it uh it's been an amazing
journey I headed up the working group to
actually help steer it into its final
phases it is now open on the 17th of
um March February we had the opening to
the next slide please
and this is the the caretaker Don now
Don uh actually closed the hall so we
thought it was very relevant that he
opened the hall as well so here he is
pulling off the plaque next one please
and there's the plaque and it's all
glory and then the final one please
yes now at this point I should should
claim something say something um
Mr Buckland with his wife were sat at
the back of the guests and I said no no
no no use it at the front
um what I didn't realize was that he was
in direct line with the confetti cannon
apparently did get his beer as well so I
do apologize for that Mr Buckland I am
sincere apologies for that but it's a
lovely event and thoroughly enjoyable
and it just shows the the quality of the
actual refurbishment it's a fantastic
facility and if anyone wants to book it
I'll give you the number later on okay
then right I think that's enough for me
thank you very much Howard
okay and I could move over now to the
leader who would like to say a few words
as well
thank you chair
uh I haven't got any photographs or
videos uh on Friday the 3rd I went to a
business breakfast at Dallas burst and
the speaker was Jeremy Wright
the shires
on Friday the 17th we held jointly with
the university Warwick and the growth
Hub a driving Innovation and growth
Summit AT what is now the University of
Warwick Innovation campus
stratford-on-avon
that new name was announced by Stuart
Croft Vice Chancellor in his opening
address at The Summit
over 60 people attended
there was a real Buzz during the event
and we took the opportunity to launch
our South Water economic strategy
perhaps the most significant learning
during the event was the significance of
scale-up businesses in generating
economic growth
and these are the ones that really do
generate the growth
on Thursday and Friday last week so I
attended the district council Network
annual conference
it's worth just recording what a few of
the Salient points I think were
first reorganization of local government
now appears to be no longer on the
agenda
there seems to be a growing
understanding of the significance of
district councils and their key role in
delivering services
there is across the board I hasten to
add regardless of politics
and increasing weariness with central
government trying to run things top down
and I thought there was a growing
willingness to actually push back on
that
um
there were a number of sessions where
economic growth actually featured
and it does seem to be that reality is
beginning to Dawn on the significance of
economic growth
it was clear and articulated frustration
with the planning policies emanating
from central government
there is a view that they appear to have
little understanding of the reality on
the ground
there was apprehension about the newly
created office for local government and
deep suspicion about its purpose on
being very brutally honest here
it may threaten local government
reserves which will be less than helpful
to us
there was a session on climate change
and there seemed to be an acceptance
that delivering Net Zero by 2050 would
in Practical and operational terms and I
stress that be far more challenging than
has yet been acknowledged
so
an interesting
last couple of weeks thank you chat
thank you Mr Brooklyn
thank you Jim
um just just one for me this afternoon
thank you and it's to thank everybody
that's been involved in relation to
putting the new sound and audio system
that you've got in place for this
afternoon when you are using the
microphones could ask that you please
speak into the microphones I know
everybody's done so so far but it just
helps the sound
um a bit better being picked up by our
viewers um
locally thank you
thank you very much and finally from me
um and I bet Liz thought she was going
to get away with it
I've got some very sad news that's
really interesting so Liz is retiring
now it's good news for her and it's sad
news for us so I'd just like to give a
quick Round of Applause for Liz for all
her help over the years
and also it's her birthday
so happy birthday Liz
I'm not going to sing Happy Birthday he
wouldn't want to hear it but well done
listen thank you for all of your support
over the years it's been most
appreciated and that is by all of us I
am absolutely certain so thank you very
much indeed really appreciate it
there's no public participation thank
you very much
so I will now move on to item seven the
political balance calculation and this
is for noting are there any comments
from members
no okay
all all happy with that noted
item eight is the uh Bishops Edgington
neighborhood development plan again
we've got two of those plans coming
through which is really excellent news
um is that councilor Pemberton yes
um
thank you chairman
um first item on page 21 of your agenda
papers is the bishop cityton
neighborhood development plan they held
their referendum on the 19th of January
and the ballot generated a 14.12
turnout of eligible voters with 274
voters supporting the plan and 40
opposing the plan so on that basis the
recommendation to cancel is that the
Bishops itching to Neighborhood
development plan is adopted with
immediate effect with the consequence
that it becomes part of the development
plan for Stratford and Ivan District
before just seeking council's approval I
just want to place on record my thanks
to the members of the Bishops itchington
neighborhood development plan group
these are large pieces of work for
communities and the the members of those
group really do put lots of hours and
hard yards in and they produce excellent
documents and this is another example of
that and I just want also to to thank
officers in the policy team particularly
Matthew Neal who leads on ndps Anders
brought brought support for Bishop
sittington in bringing this one to uh to
fruition so that's the recommendation
and and seek cancels uh agreement thank
you can I have a second over that
councilor kettle
and did you want to speak on that cancer
kettle yes
um thank you Mr chairman uh thank you Mr
Deputy leader for those comments
um yes well this isn't the first
neighborhood development plan has been
produced by settlements within Stratford
districts and no doubt it went with the
last
um but a huge amount of work has gone in
by
um the team who's been working behind
that and I'd like to commend
particularly two people the first chair
of the neighborhood Development Group
Alan Heatley who's not here
um and the last uh Norman Thomas who is
here uh Norman your team has done
fantastically well it has been a real
struggle uh we've got it over the line
so many congratulations to you and let
us look forward to this being part of
the policy documentation for Stratford
going forward so congratulations
thank you and I'm sure that goes from
all of us well done and we all know and
how difficult it is
are we all agreed
thank you
uh the next one is the Quinton
neighborhood development plan Council
Pemberton
thank you very much chair uh again uh
bringing uh forward to members of the
council the Quinton neighborhood
development plan which again on the 19th
of January went through its local
community referendum again the ballot
generated 14.1 percent of eligible
voters
with a yes vote of 267 against a no vote
of 30 so a an overwhelming endorsement
of the Quinton neighborhood development
plan so members the recommendation once
again is that the Quinton neighborhood
development plan is adopted with
immediate effect with the consequence
that it becomes part of the development
plan for stratford-on-avon district and
again I would write to place on record
my formal thanks to the Quinton
neighborhood development plan group for
all of their hard work in bringing this
plan together and the same comments I
made about Bishop teaching applied to
Quinton this is Big Ticket stuff and
it's hard work for lots of volunteers
and it's it's great to see the community
engagement because ndps are important
and again I'd also like to play some
record my thanks again to Matthew Neal
and the policy team for bringing this to
fruition so seek Castle support thank
you do I have a second for this
who's seconding it it comes the kettle
uh or are we all in agreement
thank you
all right Mr buckling would you like to
just discuss the procedure for all the
rest of the event of the items please
thank you and not all the items just the
budget item thank you chairman um I just
just wanted to clarify the arrangements
for the next couple of items on the
agenda so agenda item 10 on your agenda
is an opportunity for the leader to make
a statement in relation to the budget
that the statement will last no longer
than 10 minutes and then a
representative of the liberal Democrat
group to respond to that and I'm
informed its councilor Curtis will be
making a response again that'll be a
statement for no more than 10 minutes we
then move on to the budget items proper
which starts at item 11. what council is
going to be asked in a short while is to
suspend stand in orders to allow one
member of each group to speak more than
once on the budget items
I understand there's going to be
councilor Harvey for the conservative
group and councilor Junaid for the
liberal Democrat group
we're also going to ask Council that one
member from each group is allowed to
speak for more than five minutes which
is the tradition on the budget items and
I understand councilor Harvey will be
using that to introduce the budget item
under item 11 and it will be councilor
Junaid sorry pardon me that we'll be
responding to that thank you chairman
thank you David
um do I have agreement from Council on
this
thank you very much
thank you I now invite the leader of the
council under representative from the
liberal Democrat Group which we know is
David Curtis to make a statement for
that for the council or to the council
thank you
thank you Jack
I'm not going to go into the details of
the budget because my colleague
councilor Harvey will do that
what I want to do is make a few points
that set the context in which we created
the budget and then make a few uh
detailed points after that
key points
yet again we've had only one a one-year
settlement
that makes planning for the medium term
particularly challenging and this I
think is the fourth year running we've
only had a one-year settlement
I repeat what I said last year
we all need to fully understand the
constraints we face in setting a budget
we have to maintain a minimum Reserve
level of 3 million
section 151 officer has increased that
from Two and a half million
given the high level of inflation and
the increasing uncertainty in volatility
I think he's been both wise and prudent
I should stress it's the one section 151
officer's decision not as some
counselors appear to believe a political
decision
we just stay within this limit at the
end of five years
reserves by almost six and a half
million over the five-year period
it's got to be clearly noted that in
2027-28 we are using 2.8 million of
earmark reserves to balance the budget
so that means I think there'll be some
difficult decisions to be made in either
24 25 or 25 26 to prevent major issues
in 27 28 and Beyond
as we all know council tax increases are
capped
in our case at five pounds or 3.2
percent
last year I said we were facing an
economic Backlot of uncertainty and
volatility
this hasn't changed
inflation's now 10.1 percent is in CPI
the government's preferred measure a
year ago it was five and a half percent
once again our assumptions underpinning
the budget don't take this level of of
inflation into account
of particular significance here is the
magnitude of public sector pay claims
even one percent more than we budgeted
for will cost us about 650 000. over the
five-year medium-term Financial strategy
period
we have benefited significantly from the
increases in interest rates
base rate now stands at four percent and
could easily go higher and stay higher
for longer
however as we use reserves income from
money on deposit will diminish
there's also a move by central
government to understand
now put that in quotation marks the
reserves position of local councils
many of us
believe this is a euphemism for taking
the level of reserves into account when
setting the level of support government
gives to councils
this would not be good news for us it
introduces yet another dimension of
uncertainty
in this context we have once again been
prudent in setting the budget
despite that we preserved all services
and we've invested in growth
most notably we've increased our
spending on energy and financial advice
funding I put 250
000 into the cost of living support for
each of the next two years
these initiatives will help our most
disadvantaged residents adjust to the
cost of living crisis and still enable
us to stay within our minimum level of
reserves over the five-year period
everything I've said
clearly demonstrates the importance of
taking a strategic and long-term View
The Five-Year time Horizon gives us an
important discipline
it will be easy and irresponsible to
spend far more in the short term
and create big problems in the future
in my view shared by my colleagues
that's not the way to behave
the decision we took to introduce the
one two three word service has been
Vindicated by the government making it
very clear that councils would have to
introduce a weekly food waste collection
service I believe that's from 2025.
introducing this when we had to renew
the contractor saved money
it's also worth commenting that with the
only local Council in the area providing
such a service
and our experience and expertise is now
in demand
again it's a pragmatic illustration of
the benefits of taking sensible
long-term strategic decisions and not
being driven by short-term quick fixes
uh
I also need to comment on the unwinding
of the proposed merger with Warwick
District Council and make sure that the
financial impact on our council is
absolutely clear
the section 151 officer has confirmed
that we spend approximately
469 pounds on the virgin
as a result of continued joint work and
Incorporation
we've achieved annual recurring Savings
of 271 200. over a five-year period this
is one million three hundred and fifty
six thousand
in addition
we recharge Warwick for services
provided in respect of where Services
where our contact center deals with
residents in both areas
the recharge is approximately 150 000 a
year
so over five years that's another 750
000.
total savings over five years 2.1
million
in addition there have been one off
service estimated at one million one
hundred and forty nine thousand
for the avoidance of any doubt
these are the figures from the section
151 officer I hope everyone is now very
clear on the benefits we've gained
through going through the merger process
and that clearly demonstrates our
willingness to take full decisions in
this case both to commence merger
proceedings and to cease proceedings
when we had a major reservations
so there you have it
sound strategic decisions enabling us to
continue to provide valuable service
a willingness to provide support to our
most vulnerable residents and most
important a prudent and sustainable
budget created in the teeth of
uncertainty unpredictability and
volatility
we've been responsible we haven't
overspent
and we haven't kicked the can down the
road
and residents get this
all this for a proposed council tax of
only 159 pounds and 12 Pence
thank you chair
thank you leader
um do we have a response
cancer Curtis
thank you chair
um I'm just going to preface with what I
was going to say by reminding everyone
in the room that the section 151 officer
did look at the libden proposals and
agree that they were financially sound
and sustainable
whilst this budget is not without some
Merit
we regret that only one of the liberal
Democrat proposals has been accepted I'm
just going to go through a few points
in 2022 liberal Democrats proposed an
energy and financial advice fund
residents will welcome this support
especially during this conservative
government's massive increase in energy
costs
hitting our residents which sees
consumer in UK Energy prices
over double the EU average
cost of living fund
we welcome the cost of living fund of
250 000 for the next two years
we had proposed that this should have
been at three hundred thousand but this
will still still support residents
hardest hit by conservative cost of
living crisis
we regret however that cabinet refused
our request to write to ministers and
local MPS asking for Action through the
delivery of a real increase in
investment in UK Renewables Energy
Efficiency and agreeing plan for the UK
which leads me to our proposed climate
change initiatives
rejected by cabinet
we made three proposals
a grant fund to address energy usage in
community buildings and other community
activities
a grant scheme to allow rural
communities better access
to allow better access to climate change
initiatives
and the scheme to encourage owners of
large rural buildings to invest in
rooftop solar panels as we see in many
other European countries
taking our proposal for a grant scheme
to give rural communities better access
to climate change initiatives I do agree
with comments made at cabinet by
councilors shenton Harvey and Fleming
that such proposals should come before
the climate change panel
the leader said there is a process set
up
councilor Harvey said
lack of money cannot be one of the
reasons these proposals have not gone to
the count to the CCP
is clearly correct
as at the end of period 8 in 2023
less than 30 000 pounds had been spent
from this fund leaving a balance of 896
000 pounds in the climate change
emergency fund
the portfolio holder councilor Fleming
went on to say nothing has ever come to
me on any of these topics we proposed
a resident recently emailed asking what
funding would be available for Village
Hall climate change initiatives
seems to me like this would be something
that would allow rural communities
better access to climate change funding
she was told by the program director for
climate change
the only local funding I am aware
is County council's green shoots fund
however this is currently closed
it seems from the conservative's
rejection of our proposals and our
request to write the government that
although they profess to support climate
change initiatives the rhetoric is not
borne out by reality
is this a climate change emergency or
not
over 66 over 66 parking scheme we regret
the cabinet has not even agreed to
review this scheme the evidence produced
to withdraw the scheme in the first
instance was flimsy and no evidence of
increased car parking revenues has been
produced
the district has an aging population and
liberal Democrats wish to encourage
greater activity and participation among
our older residents
the five ways of well-being highlights
connecting being active keeping learning
giving and taking notice and we believe
that reintroducing a 66 plus parking
scheme would encourage our older
residents in these five ways of
well-being
reducing strain and costs to other
health services
and also increasing economic economic
activity within the town
planning enforcement additional
resources we are delighted that this
budget amendment has been accepted
resident and Parish councils often feel
their voice is ignored and we hope this
additional funding
plus a more robust approach to
enforcement will ensure that no one no
one however wealthy or exalted their
position
will be able to flout such planning
regulations
shop Mobility visits visit visitor
information center and Venture House
shop Mobility was of course a liberal
Democrat initiative and we do welcome to
Contin continued financial support in
these three areas
central government grant funding
rather than identifying need
this government's approach to local
Authority funding is highly competitive
Andy Street the conservative mayor for
West Midlands lashed out of the process
calling for an end to this broken
bigging Bowl culture
last year we proposed an officer post
dedicated to grant writing to increase
our competitiveness in this key area
seeking investment in skills
infrastructure jobs and innovation
a cabinet counselor Perry Perry I do beg
your pardon counselor Perry councilor
Perry
oh but I still bigger I would still
apologize
made much of the 25 million awarded to
this Council since 2017.
roughly four and a half million pounds
per annum
so let's look at the results of some of
our nearest Neighbors
um that are some of our nearest
neighbors have achieved from leveling up
none eaten and bedworth
14.9 million bromsgrove Town Center
regeneration 14 and a half million
Shropshire Council Riverside
Redevelopment
18.7 million
Malvern Hills District Council they hit
the jackpot
19.9 million
oh sorry Stratford District Council
25 000 pounds to oxhill Village Hall
I'll leave it there
finally I know the cabinet papers for
16th of January says
the government is continuing to
experience difficulties managing demands
on the public purse and the scale of the
national deficit
this has been exaggered exacerbated by
the war in Ukraine and the resultant
inflation caused by supply chain issues
energy costs and consumer demand
this increases the possibility of
further funding reductions at the level
of District councils
however the papers failed to mention
that this conservative government
has cut local Authority funding by 40
percent from 42 billion to 25 billion
it fails to mention the disastrous trust
quoting mini budget which has cost
taxpayers anything from 36 30 to 60
billion and of course it doesn't fails
to mention the Tory brexit
which call is the London School of
economics has added three percent to
inflation and the UK economy is five
percent smaller
the war in Ukraine is clearly beyond the
beyond the control of the UK
but why did the cabinet papers not
mention the disastrous impact of these
Tory policies on funding for district
councils
these conservative policies are calling
real hardship to our business community
and our residents
yet this Administration
refuses to criticize our MP or the
government
it's time for a change
thank you chair
thank you I think you sprayed off the
budget today of the Stratford District
Council a little bit there Mr Curtis but
anyway
right
um members
the I'm moving this motion that is the
council procedure rule 15.5 when a
councilor may speak again be waived to
allow one nominated member from each
group to speak more than once on the
budget related items do I get a second
for that
thank you very much indeed okay or are
we all agreed or I'm asking for a vote
on this one please
thank you very much okay then that's
passed thank you
right let's move on to the next item
um item 11 Revenue minute 7579 revenue
and capital budget 2023 24 to 2027-28
to consider the recommendation from the
cabinet as contained in minute 579 of
its meeting held on the 13th of February
uh I hope you all brought your papers
with you right
yes I informed the meeting that in
accordance with the local authorities
standing orders England Amendment
regulations 2014 a recorded vote will be
taken on the revenue and capital budgets
2023-27 to 2728
right
um I've noted councilor yes drewnet and
rock have printed I invite though first
of all Council Harvey is a portfolio
holder for resources to introduce this
item
signaling something but I'm not quite
sure what it is Council Rock did you
want to
that's it that's it thank you can't work
the new technology despite my practice
previously and I I just checking uh
chairman we seem to have moved on from
item 11 before we've had a chance to
make a comment upon it is that uh it's a
question on process chatting thank you
very much
item 11 now
we've just had item 10 which is the two
statements so if I didn't make that
clear at the beginning but the item 10
was just two statements we're now moving
on to item 11 and the budget is about to
be proposed I think by councilor Harvey
I apologize for getting in front of
myself chairman thank you I'm perfectly
all right
um
may I ask a
your brilliant Amendment forward
on this
well that's okay let's go through the
council for Harvey first then thank you
delayed
thank you Mr chairman
the leader has outlined much of the
context against which we've had to
develop the budget this year I make no
apologies for amplifying some of the
points he made as they demonstrate the
challenges we face and will continue to
face
the economic backdrop to the preparation
of the budget for the next financial
year has been very mixed at this time
last year there was the risk of of war
that regrettably turned into reality
Russia's invasion of Ukraine has led to
profound consequences for people and
economies around the world most notably
the disruption of energy and Food
Markets with consequences for inflation
rates around the world
domestically we have to a significant
significant extent recovered from the
economic and social consequences of the
covid-19 pandemic with high levels of
employment
changing work practices and an
acceleration in the trend towards a
cashless Society together with
increasing Reliance generally on digital
technology
the government has borrowed prodigious
amounts of money
to meet the costs of the pandemic
although fortunately not as much as some
would have borrowed last Autumn to fund
significant tax cuts in an ill-founded
hope that the world that this would
generate levels of economic growth that
would defy the gravity of markets and
resolve the country's fundamental
economic issues
Council Curtis
economic decisions and their
consequences over the past 12 months
both internationally and domestically
have led to inflation rates in the UK
and around the world that have not been
seen since the 1970s
but this time in February 2021 consumer
prices were increasing at the rate of
0.4 percent
in a survey of economic forecast
provided by 30 organizations published
in the Sunday Times on the 19th of
February the most accurate forecaster
proved to be Capital economics
this organization forecast last year
that inflation at the end of 2022 would
be running at 4.3 percent
in reality it was running at 10.8
percent
similarly Capital economics expected
bank rate at the end of last year to be
1.25 when in reality it turned out at
the time to be three and a half and
currently is four
and now we have an economist group at
Citibank forecasting that the UK's
inflation rate will be down to 2.3
percent in November 2023 whilst at the
same time members of the bank of
England's monetary policy committee are
suggesting that the base rate needs to
be increased still further and
maintained at a higher rate for the rest
of 2023 in order for inflation to
subside to its Target of two percent
the words of the American economist John
Kenneth Galbraith come to mind when he
said the only function of economic
forecasting is to make astrology look
respectable
this is the uncertain economic
background against which the budget for
2324 has been prepared and which then
forms the basis for the council's
medium-term financial strategy over the
next five years like citizens of the UK
generally the residents of Stratford
District are coping with the largest
squeeze on their living standards for a
generation
the council's finances for the county
are demonstrate the uncertainties with
which the council has had to cope
at this time last year the forecast
outturn was that the council would incur
a deficit of 880 000 pounds that would
be financed by drawing on the council's
general Reserve
the latest forecast for the current year
is the council will report a surplus of
approximately one million pounds rather
than the original budgeted deficit of a
hundred and sixteen thousand having
taken into account the Under and Over
budgeting outturns elsewhere in the
budget this result will be almost
entirely due to one factor the impact of
the unanticipated rate of interest rates
during the past year generating
unexpected income from the council's
balances of an additional 1.5 million
pounds in interest earnings
such year-on-year fluctuations
demonstrate the difficulty of the budget
setting process the underlying strategic
Financial issue the council faces
however Remains The Changing structure
of the sources of finance of its Revenue
this year's spending review was the
proverbial cure its egg
the review was another disappointment
because for the fourth consecutive year
It produced a settlement for one year
rather than a four-year period
this means that local authorities lack
the certainty of their financial
framework for a reasonable period over
which they can then plan
that said the picture I've tried to
paint about the uncertainties of the
British economy currently faces is the
real world background against which
government has to make its judgments the
spending review did however have some
good news for the district whilst this
will be the last year that the council
will receive new homes bonus payment of
1.9 million pounds from central
government this element of funding has
been replaced by the introduction of a
three percent funding guarantee of 2.2
million pounds
whilst this is good news in the short
term for our ability to continue to
finance the council's current range and
level of service provision the pressure
on the council's finances to fund
Services beyond the next financial year
remain undiminished
that said councilors will have noted
that the budget proposed is for a
deficit of 936
000 pounds that its proposed will be
funded from the general Reserve in Broad
terms therefore the financial
overachievement beg your pardon
the financial over achievement in the
current year is being deliberately used
to fund a planned deficit for next year
the specific budget proposals approved
by the cabinet on the 16th of January
was set out on pages 105 to 109 of the
relevant paper and have now been the
subject of consultation
in Broad summary
the budget makes provision not only for
the continued provision of the council's
range of services it also includes
provision for additional staff in a
number of areas to bolster and add to
that provision
I'll draw attention however to only two
items which recognize and respond to the
difficulties with which some residents
are grappling
the first is the doubling of the
allocation that's coming here to a
hundred thousand pounds to support the
work of act on energy for the provision
of advice to Residents concerning their
energy and financial concerns and second
to the creation of a cost of living
support fund of 250 000 pounds for each
of the next two years to be targeted
directly to those most in need
the proposed budget also takes into
account the proposals put forward by the
liberal Democrat group
these included three proposals which
fall within the remit of the climate
change panel
not only has an additional five hundred
thousand pounds being allocated within
next year's budget for climate change
initiatives they remain unallocated
funds Under The Heading under this
heading within this year's budget these
three proposals should therefore be put
to the climate change panel for its
considerations
the proposal for additional resource
suggested for the discretionary planning
enforcement team has been accepted and
broadened to enable the relevant head of
service to use across the range of his
enforcement and Regulatory
responsibilities as he judges will be to
the greatest effect in the interests of
residents generally
The Proposal that additional resource
should be allocated to employ a grant
writing officer is not new
it's been discussed on a number of
occasions and rejected for sound reasons
that are well known
the suggestion that certain service
reviews should be undertaken is not
accepted for reasons that my respective
colleagues will be happy to outline
subsequently if this would be helpful to
councilors
the acid test for the finances of this
council is the level of its reserves
over the five-year period of the
medium-term financial strategy
unless it can be shown that the minimum
level of his reserves increased by the
section 151 officer this year from Two
and a half million pounds to three
million pounds can be maintained
both throughout this period and above
this threshold any such budget proposals
would not be viable the section 151
officer would simply not approve them
the budget proposals before Council
today do essentially two things first
they again protect the council's ability
to provide its residents with the range
and quality of the services they
currently enjoy for the forthcoming
Financial year and secondly despite the
need for decisions in the subsequent
four years the proposed budget
demonstrates that the necessary minimum
level reserves can be maintained
throughout the period although they are
projected nevertheless to decline to
close to three million pounds
I'm the first to recognize that all of
the district's residents have
experienced our experience are
experiencing and will continue to
experience in the coming 12 months
pressure on their budgets as a result of
the increases in the cost of living
in such an inflation environment it
would not be unexpected however if the
council was to increase the portion of
the overall council tax
while the proposed increase of five
pounds for a ban D property is the
maximum allowed by by legislation
without a referendum it represents an
increase of only 3.2 percent
given the financial challenges the
council continues to face this seems a
modest increase to enable the council to
meet its service obligations to its
residents
providing this budget has been a very
much a team effort I'd like to place on
record my thanks to those members of the
business community and to those
residents who contributed to the
feedback processes to my colleagues
within the cabinet and the conservative
group and in particular to the diligent
work of Richard Burrell or section 151
officer and to all members of the
finance department team who've been so
supportive I invite members of the
council therefore to approve the budget
proposals for 23-24 as set out in the
papers and have pleasure informally
proposing the recommendation set out on
page 27 of the paper thank you very much
Gemma thank you very much indeed I'm
looking for a second there
councilor Jefferson thank you very much
indeed uh members Council Harvey did
overrun some what
um however I will allow that for the
response as well so we'll have exactly
the same time on that particular Point
councilor Junaid you did ask to speak
first yes
I'm taking the long-term View and that
was mentioned earlier
I am proud to be the former leader of
this Council that was responsible for
the foundation of the Energy Efficiency
charity that is now act on energy
almost 25 years ago and I remain a
trustee and that is declared on my
Declarations of Interest
25 years ago
in February 2022 an amendment was made
by the liberal Democrat group
that address the need for the housing
team to develop financial and other
advice for householders facing a looming
energy crisis
February 2022
it took months for the council to sort
out how the funds would be used but we
now know note note that the scheme
eventually developed has proved so
successful that more money is to be made
available
this is to be welcomed
but with a caveat
in 2013 in my professional role
I wrote the final West Midlands report
for deck
on the way in which the green deal and
fuel poverty pilot projects functioned
in the West Midlands
these projects tested the way in which a
range of insulation Energy Efficiency
projects
and fuel poverty work would be could be
delivered mostly by local authorities
and communities
Stratford District Council did not take
part
the key lessons were made clear by the
councils I interviewed and worked with
yet none of those lessons were taken on
board by government
the green deal was scrapped by the
conservatives in 2015 along with other
energy saving measures
the number of homes having their Lofts
or cavity walls insulated each year
dropped by 92 percent
and 74 respectively
and have never recovered
I personally know of businesses that
went bust at that time because they had
thought that the green deal would be
delivered
now Ten Years Later
we're still talking about basic
interventions
such as decent insulation cost effective
efficient heating to prevent damper mold
I'm having to visit far too many
families with small children who are
desperately trying to get help
I spoke to orbit this week about the
number of cases of damper mold in their
accommodation in this District
Ten Years Later
from that report
we're in a cost of living crisis
and we are scrabbling to cope with the
consequences for our residents no
preparation
no foresight
just expensive responses to a crisis
once it had happened
no lessons learned
can I make it clear
everybody here
I want our residents to be supported in
facing up to the difficult year ahead
they have already had a very difficult
year
the funds for the cost of living crisis
and the energy crisis are to be welcomed
this is what we have asked for as
liberal Democrats
but just as so many the other actions
were taken so long at government level
as well as local government level
these actions have also come very late
in this crisis
and too often we see this Council
dragged Kicking and Screaming into
taking action
and I have no confidence anymore
that any of the lessons will be learned
it will be business as usual just as at
a government level
until the next Crisis
both locally and nationally I think this
is the way things are going
I welcome that the proposal for extra
planning enforcement has been accepted
very much needed
we're now asking for more attention to
be paid to the climate change agenda
four years ago I moved the climate
emergency motion
but I'm afraid that no one is listening
to or properly engaging with those who
can Implement change rapidly and
permanently
it is not being treated seriously enough
and I have little confidence anymore in
the ability of this leadership to
deliver
I have even less confidence in the
national government to to deliver
The Institute for government has just
put out a report
that made the case clearly by saying
that local councils and their
communities are the best route for
delivery
in that report they said the present
bidding schemes were judged by them to
be highly inefficient
Westminster Hasler has to learn to let
go and allow councils to lead their
communities and for their communities to
be fully involved to tackle the problems
ahead
and if we're to support our communities
we have to develop the economy our small
of our small businesses and high streets
to allow this to happen help is needed
to develop business plans and apply for
funds
so in conclusion I'm just saying that
some of the things that we have
suggested we welcome that the fact that
they've been taken on board
too little too late but they've been
taken on board
what I'm saying is I'm not sure that any
of them I'm not confident that any of
them were actually possib properly be
delivered in the coming year ahead thank
you
thank you Council
um right we've had the opening remarks
and from cancer Judith may I remind
members please to stick to what is on
the agenda is the budget for this
Council please some of you may notice
there's a an election coming up
but let's just stick to what um yeah
it's a surprise let's just stick to the
agenda to please thank you very much
indeed members right uh who else would
you like to speak on this
cancer Curtis and Council Rock
thank you Jeff
um before I move on to the liberal
Democrat amendments
um listening to councilor Harvey and the
leader
one may be forgiven to think that um the
lib demons are intent on plunging the
district council into some sort of
financial chaos
I would just like
thank you thank you but I would just
like to remind everyone
that the lib Dem proposals
were approved by the um task and finish
group
and I would also like to thank the
section 151 officer Richard Burrell for
his very very thorough examination of
our proposals and the fact that he
agreed that they are all clear
achievable and financial sound
financially sound
um however that aside I would just like
to move on to agenda item 11
the Amendments by the liberal Democrats
please the zero carbon fund of 150 000
the rural you have these on the yellow
papers
started like propose those amendments
thank you
you're moving that so do I have a second
to please
thanks very much indeed
anyone now councilor Rock did you want
to speak on this
not on the amendment chairman so I'm not
quite sure as ever about the sequence of
events to do things properly you're
always very keen to do so um it was on a
general point on page 27 so if that's an
appropriate place I'll speak on that now
if not no we're going to discuss the
amendment now but thank you very much
thank you chairman so so who would like
to speak on the amendment
in that case then
we'll take it to the vote thank you very
much indeed oh sorry Council shanton
just pointed clarification if I speak on
this will I be excluded from speaking
later on on General no because you're
speaking the amendment then you get the
opportunity to speak on the emotion of
English okay I'll continue thank you
Jeff
um
we're talking about this amendment
councilor Curtis these you're talking
about those
it sort of Beggars belief
that you would you would accuse us of
not being climate friendly
it's smacks of autocracy rather than
democracy from the lib Dems because
you know full well that three of these
items should have gone through the
climate change fund they're very fun
that your members sit on councilor
together councilor junid
there's no question
that we are saying no it has to go
through those funds first so through
that process you are trying to subvert
the process
quite clearly
what you're saying is nothing more than
if you like hubery and hot air
you really do need to follow the process
there is a process nobody has said you
cannot these can't come forward but they
must go through the climate change fund
so there's no question about that as far
as your
I don't know if you want to cover off
the whether I can cover off the the uh
the other proposals that they they put
forward
um
you spoke about
um you're talking about the over 65s
permits you've
um spoken a great lens about the
benefits of that you've also spoken on
one or two other matters
however
the lib Dems
record on climate change is not great
you failed on the one thing that you
could have done
that would Aid climate change you failed
to vote for the one two three plus
yet you have the temerity to stand up
there and lecture us this is incredible
this is two-facedness at the best
hypocrisy from the lib Dems I have to
say is nothing short of green washing
the lib Dems are known for this you come
up with lots of things that you know
can't be delivered you made a claim
that a resident sent an email in he made
a claim about that
but why why wasn't that bought to the
climate change panel in if you felt so
strongly about it why wasn't it well
there's no point shaking your head
cancer pair together why didn't you
bring It Forward
again
hot air absolute hot air
so I I just I stand here
actually amazed at that you you can come
forward with this I'm just trying to
looking down my notes here I've got so
many notes
um
yeah yeah a bit of scribble scrub them
all out I think yeah as I go through
them
you know
you you spoke about the over the about
the over 60 you've brought up the over
65s issue did nobody tell you that we're
supposed to be trying to discourage
um driving and did have you not noticed
that the cost of living crisis uh
affects not just over 65s but everyone
and yet you would have us put money into
another scheme that very few councils in
the whole of the UK including any of
your own uh actually do
um I'm just looking again down down the
notes Here
I think oh yes I know the other one the
planning enforcement you made some some
comment there as well about
um no one will be able to flout the
system effectively because of their
standing
again hubri you haven't pour anything
forward to say what that was all about
so you make this General accusation that
we need a more robust approach to
planning enforcement
but without saying why other than making
a generalized comment
you really do need to pick your words
carefully so
for my part I oppose all of these
amendments Jeff and I oppose the other
proposals especially as they say
there'll be no cost to the investigation
um I'm guessing that they presume that
officers are sitting waiting five
seconds telephone for them to just get
up and answer the answer these questions
thank you chair thank you
both take was canceled Bromwich
and now
okay
thank you sorry I understood that we
were talking on the amendment not the uh
the moment at hole and councilor shenton
seemed to have gone off peace and what
and started talking about other other
things which weren't covered by the
amendment as it was
they are this is on the amendment
they are on the amendment
yeah well the surprise I can see it
might have gone off peace a little bit
but no I think in general it was is on
on the amendment I was keeping an eye on
that particular point
Council Bromwich
yeah first of all um obviously thank you
chairman for your allowing the leeways
that the various people spoken so far to
deviate from what the actual issues are
however I go to try and stick to what's
in front of us and not do any
politicking
so I know the lip dem's amendments here
when I look down this some quite a bit
of this actually should be more engaging
with our Parish councils on a lot of
this sort of thing then actually a
district level because in the end we're
meant to be doing democracy at a local
level and encouraging that
we as District councils can advise we
get a lot of information through
but I'm not seeing much justification
for pain out money that actually if we
work with our communities properly we
can find out that information
I pick up on councilor Curtis on the
parking permits
what points of parking permit if you
live in southam It's All Ships don't
arrest now let's have a proper look at
this and say is it politicking and
benefiting for the few or as it should
be engaging the whole District
so when we come up with policies
regardless of political persuasion we
should always ask ourselves is it the
benefit for the whole District not just
park district and that goes for any
budget amendment
where the benefits as I said some of
this could actually be quite a lot of it
can be done by Parish councils
and parking permits as I said doesn't
benefit the whole District
then I come to when it comes to Green
issues
and these have been bought up as well as
part of this
you can throw money all you want at
Green issues
but it has to start with basic education
and understanding
that starts as individuals educating
your residence
you can stand there and you can say I
can provide all this money to provide
all this insulation in the world
but then you have to turn around and say
does the person understand the
consequences does that person actually
really truly understand if we want to be
so eco-friendly you'd all be joining me
Council Crump would be joining me at my
father's allotment at weekends happily
digging away and we'd be digging for
victory again
we
but that is the reality if you want to
go perfectly green that then ask
yourselves this are you going to the
supermarket or are you growing your own
for example those small things have a
bigger impact on climate change and any
chocolate councils governments of money
it's more important to educate than it
is to talk at money endlessly
we can eventually get to what the goals
are when people say about insulation
but we have to do it in a pragmatic way
and not be sucking big money all at once
and certainly as a local Authority it
shouldn't be our job this is direction
from national government we are we are
able to only do a small amount as a
district council
and a lot of that amount is about us as
counselors and we get all get allowances
looking up the information and providing
our Essence with the information because
that is cheaper than us putting the
council tax up and stinging the
residents for five minutes on the
internet
thank you councilman
uh Council Jefferson
thank you chair
I was very interested in World counselor
Curtis said
a resident emailed him about the
possibility of money
what happened
nothing
this is absolutely typical of the
liberal Democrats
lots of noise lots of talk lots of
whinging lots of whining absolutely no
action
that could easily have been turned into
a proposal to go to the climate change
panel for money it wasn't
this is absolutely typical where there
are complaints but absolutely zero
action
foreign
Council Fielding
thank you chair when we had the climate
change emergency debate
I was the only one who abstained on the
grounds we didn't know what was coming
around the corner
I think there's a bit of a car crash
going on here we now need to have more
gas produced
we need a whole lot of additions to the
green emergency that
don't make it work for instance
we we run out of wind every now and
again we run out of Sun every now and
again and we keep wanting to do away
with agricultural land
we need every acre for food
just because Morocco's had a
um
a lot of um you know it's Frost we're
running out of tomatoes
I will leave it at that I have said what
I wanted thank you very much
um councilman did you have a point of
order it's a point of correction if I
may share we don't have points of
Correction point but it's a good try a
point if it's a point at a genuine point
of order yes
um just to be clear
I did not say that I had received an
email that's not a point of order the
can climate change okay sorry okay thank
you climate change director thank you
councilor Curtis no action had been
taken thank you character Curtis right
point of order or stick to the agenda
please right Council Wally hoggins next
thank you
thank you Chad I've sat here with some
bewilderment really listening to various
colleagues in this Council chamber today
because what I see as this proud
conservative council is that we have as
conservatives on a national level and
I'm bringing this up even though I'm
referring to this uh these amendments
because they the lib Dems do bring these
matters up the conservatives gave out
169 billion pounds in Kobe grants and
100 million pounds worth of billion
pounds worth of that went to individuals
to make sure that they were okay during
the pandemic so I can't listen to any
more calls for any more money being
given to anybody
however the reason I'm going to the
Amendments now is that the
um economic business support 50 000
pounds a year to create jobs actually
it's from where we're sitting for many
of us here I have people who are
employers it isn't a question of
creating jobs there are plenty of jobs
out there it is a question of actually
attracting people into those jobs we
talk here about zero carbon funds to
enable reviews and measures to address
energy usage but what this Council has
done and we fail to say a little bit
here is this conservative Council has
empowered residents to do their bit as
far as the green and gender is concerned
they they've been collection service
that has changed and evolved over the
last four years has been exemplary we
are now being held up I believe as a
beacon of a beacon of of
um good practice amongst other councils
and other councils will most
determinedly be following following our
lead I'd also like to bring to order
about the statements about rural
building solar panels there has to be
some uh careful consideration about this
because we are proudly within the
Cotswold aonb those of us in the most
rural areas and we have to be careful
about the solar panels that are being
installed because there are many
varieties of that and also encouraging
people to install them it's all very
well
specifying grants such as that but
actually the cost of fitting solar
panels now has increased exponentially
don't ask me to spell that however what
that actually means is from first-hand
experience
pre-pre-pandemic it would have possibly
cost around six to seven thousand Pounds
to install solar panels on a roof to uh
to fuel to if you like to power your own
electricity so that you could be
off-grid however anecdotally just on
domestic premises alone now that bill
has now doubled if not tripled in order
to make that happen that is beyond the
reach of most people building homes and
making alterations so although I
recognize that the opposition is allowed
to put these amendments there I think
far more greater consideration needs to
be given to that and I think we also
need to thank our residents for the hard
work that they have done to date just by
filling their bins because actually
they're doing a brilliant job at doing
that they've embraced the changes that
we've brought before them and I would
like to say thank you very much to our
residents and to all officers who've
brought that to pass thank you thank you
councilor I can't do that
can I just remind
councilors that it was in last year's
budget
that we proposed a separate climate
change budget that was very similar to
the one presented today
it was based on one successfully
implemented by Cambridge District
Council
and by other councils across the country
that I did research on
it was refused A year ago
some of the most successful climate
change schemes in this District have
been carried out by parish councils and
by Community groups
and I could name quite a few of them
that have been very very successful and
we need to build on that
and then put other parts of the country
and I think in this part in some parts
of this District as well they've
actually driven new businesses
can I remind counselors that at one time
this Council was a leader and won awards
for its local Agenda 21 initiative
it just shows that we can be leaders I
would like us to be leaders again thank
you
thank you councilor Juliet yes and um
I'm sure you all agree with that uh
Council Rock
thinker chairman I wasn't proposing to
speak on this item but I've just been
listening to the debate with great
interest as you might expect
um I just wanted to pick up on a couple
of things and particularly councilor
shenton's and I think the leaders
assertion that nothing has been done
um I think the process for getting
uh for drawing on the climate change
budget
has let us say evolved because the
example I would give him is that one one
of my parishes
asked for some funding for climate
change initiatives locally which was
actually an infrared camera and we're
told by officers that this Council has
no means of funding that you should go
to the green shoots now I accept that
and this is not to Christmas with
anybody the thing is has evolved since
then and we've got this uh now we've had
this process it would seem uh for doing
it for the climate change panel but I
when I had that response I brought that
to the deputy chief executive who
conceded we need to clean up that
process and improve it a bit there's no
question for anybody we learn about
these things but to my idea that we
haven't got anything and I'm happy to
forward the emails in question to
councilor shenton
um secondly
um my colleague here from southam I
fully support his concern that we get a
good share of the action over in the
East and I I would absolutely support
him in that respect as it happens with
the uh it would appear we're not going
forward with any sort of system for the
uh retired uh parking Arrangements but
the idea had it have gone forward is we
have a Ringo system here we've got a
Ringo system in Warwick we're in close
partnership with Warwick even though
we've withdrawn from the merger
and The Proposal which we have discussed
just before the private information of
counselors is that could we work
together with them because those of us
in the use of the district are much
closer to Warwick district and a system
could be involved to deal with that so
it wasn't in our mind exclusively to the
town of Stratford and I would agree with
him in that respect that we need to make
things happen across the district
um and I would just remind uh remind
ourselves that we are the opposition and
we are here to hold the administration
to account and I'm sorry if uh if
members of the administration don't like
that but that's what we're here for
thank you very much indeed noted
councilor Rock and thank you very much
indeed to that cancer project
thank you
um yeah just to get on back onto the um
onto the subject of what we're talking
about
um
[Applause]
just about I shall hold you to that now
but I am rather suspicious that this
this bun fight that's going on might
have something to do with some elections
in May so I think um I think there is
some thought to have there um I think
what the liberal Democrats with these
proposals are indicating a direction of
travel
um and I don't think anyone can disagree
with any of these
um these proposals in that sense
um perhaps they could be
talked about with the conservative group
in a perhaps in a in a better way so
that they can be thought through and
then agreed through other processes so
there is a degree of electioneering
going on here but I think they're quite
Noble causes as well
um so I think in in that sense I'll
probably support them
um but um yeah I think um councilor
shenton probably doesn't help that um he
thinks what they're doing is
undemocratic because quite clearly it is
democratic it's a council chamber
they're putting some proposals forward
they can be disagreed with and voted
against so
um and I think any opposition group
should be doing that thank you
thank you uh Council Pemberton
uh thank you very much Council and um
picking up on uh councilor Floyd check's
theme I shall try to keep to the uh to
the exam question although for most of
this morning seems to or this afternoon
it seems to have been in more in the uh
the breached and the observance
um so first of all councilor for check
talked about a direction of travel to be
followed and I'm and I'm glad to say
that the liberal Democrats are following
where we lead
um
and equally I I relish opposition I just
think it'd be a lot more interesting if
you were much better at it
so
councilor Rock has helpfully confirmed
that
um there is work underway to ensure that
the mechanism for projects through the
climate change panel which all members
of this Council have acknowledged
um does need some work
um which for me would then knock out the
need for items one two and three of the
budget amendment because the ACT the the
the question seems to be uh from your
perspective as an opposition that the
only way to get these things done is
through the main budget process
um where in actual fact our argument
which is legitimate is that there is a
climate change panel which can assess
projects and draw uh recommend drawing
down on the funds that are there so I'm
glad that councilor rock acknowledges
that the deputy that the chief executive
and the officer team are working to make
sure that the sort of money sort of
release process works better I think the
answer is to take those three items work
with officers flesh them out and if they
work and they fly I think everybody will
be happy to support them because
uh we are looking to lead on climate
change issues
um and we take a different view as to
how to do these things we're trying to
assure get things done and uh Chancellor
Wally hoggins was absolutely right that
one of the biggest contributors from
this Castle's perspective
to helping us all towards uh Net Zero
has been the introduction of the one two
three plus system it has seen a
reduction in
um tonnage going into landfill
we are in the process of developing with
other local authorities locally a
world-leading materials recycling
facility so we're investing everybody's
money in those kinds of things and
that's why I say we're leading and the
opposition is following we're all in the
same direction of travel which is
towards net zero but we're making sure
that it can happen rather than just come
up with ideas that aren't really fleshed
out so on that basis I will not be
supporting the amendment I do understand
it it is the opposition's duty to oppose
um but I think
that yeah you need to do your homework a
bit more about bringing real pros real
things to the table and what you have
done
we've taken them on board the idea last
year the 50 000 pounds for action on
energy was supported it was a good idea
and we've taken that on board and we've
expanded the funding for it for this
year the idea about uh you know
additional support on enforcement is a
good idea we're taking it on board we
are open to good ideas personally I'll
steal anybody's good idea if it's going
to make a difference to our residents so
I will give you credit for those too but
generally
there's not enough in here and that's
why we're not going to support it thank
you thank you Council Pemberton uh
Council patiala last speaker I think
oh
all right
okay then right we'll put you down in
the list hold on
okay thank you chair so tackling climate
change and helping our community scoping
with the climate crisis should be at the
heart of the Council budget
a couple of years ago we proposed a
climate change fund
for our local communities and Parish
councils and the then portfolio holder
and forgive me I can't remember who he
was because there's been so many
portfolio holders for climate change
so this will be discussed by the climate
change panel but that's not been done to
date there is no mechanism for our
communities and our Parish councils to
access the funding that is now available
under the climate change panel
um so we're still waiting for that and
that's why we don't have any confidence
in this conservative Administration to
put climate at the heart of our policies
in the long term thank you
thank you councilor Council Adam
all three hands went up at the same time
so I've made a guess alphabetical
thank you Mr chairman um yes well no I'd
very much like to support the amendment
um it's
something that you know ultimately we're
trying to aggregate the thing that's
been in the budget and we have an
underspend on there's a significant
amount of money that we haven't
committed uh or have committed but
haven't spent which could have been uh
dedicated to schemes such as the ones
we're proposing here which is why we're
trying to break it down into a way that
can be accessed by our residents for our
residents uh I'd like to say you know
since I've been elected
um for the whole term of office I
remember almost the first week I've had
conversations with officers other
counselors and or more importantly my
residents saying we need more solar
panels on people's roofs we need these
to be approved or to go forward when we
approve
um things so to then hear uh councilor
hoggins say oh well the costs have gone
up well they probably need some help
with the cost then
exactly and I'm actually informed that
it's dropped and having uh put them on
on uh people's roofs as an engineer in
the past I can say it is very achievable
with the support which we can get which
we can give as a local Authority that's
why I am supporting uh this
um Amendment and I think it's a
perfectly sensible well-costed way to
aggregate the committed monies that we
have in our budget and the way in which
we commit that to support our residents
in this critical issue which we have all
dedicated uh time and Airport we've all
said that this is a way to do it I'm
sick of hearing oh you're not doing it
quite the right way we're trying to do
it now
thank you councilor and not quite in
alphabetical order countercrump
right it was working earlier I know what
it was it was age before Beauty that's
what it was
um right
just make it clear and again sticking
trying to stick to the the agenda is
I'll be opposing the amendment
on our slightly change of phrase an old
old phrase
spend in Heist repentant Leisure it's
offered that somewhere before might be
slightly changed so let's spend the
money wisely we have got the fund that
the 900 000 with uh commitments of 30
000 pounds spent according to councilor
Curtis who was on the working group with
me and we worked well didn't we cancel
um so yeah let's spend the money wisely
um what I don't agree with with let's
have a a fund of another fund that's
stick it in a mobile place we know where
the money is spent and let's make it
easy for Mr Burr and his team to monitor
because having worked in local
government sometimes the decisions made
by councilors don't always make sense so
it's not easy to put into operation
um
we talk about rural buildings solar
panels climate change initiatives
so we have got this climate change
emergency I totally
accept that and I endorse it and
certainly with my time to count it my
gas and electric bills have been really
low you know so which honestly so it's
my excuse for saving energy but the
serious point we're looking for these
items yet we have loads of planning
applications to serve the panels in
rural areas oh no we don't want them
and some all those are really good idea
some are really good plants but they get
turned down
um
going back to the over 65s
car parking I think there should be
quite a few Declarations of interest in
this building
[Laughter]
fortunately not quite that I might look
over 65 I feel like over 65 but I'm not
quite over 65. and it just seemed to be
a lack of clarity which counts the
Bromwich pointed out in the east of the
district because it seemed to be
stratford-centered Stratford on Ivan I
started Town Center
I did notice that counts the rock
mentioned the Ringo system
will that be done by volunteers driving
VW Beetles by any chance cancel The Rock
oh
so to sum up I know you really enjoyed
that
um
interesting about the grants as well
that we've talked about in the bidding
um
it's going back to level 65 sorry I got
to find myself again we're trying to
reduce travel and a round trip for
southern residence is 40 miles plus so
again yeah I don't think that's great
but okay this has been some
clarification from from cancer oxide so
to accept that but there's some
comparison about the grants earlier on
um being raised and the possibility of
an economic support uh to seek
investment we do forget that on the 7th
of December Mr Brooklyn told us about
the shared Prosperity fund that we're
getting 3.6 million pounds from
and we were also compared Benchmark with
none better with
which he doesn't have any Parish
councils it's mainly an urban area and
is far far smaller so let's compare
apples with apples Ringo with Ringo
pairs with pears but not Stratford
district with non-night in bedworth
thank you
thank you Council Barker
um just a couple of points of
information and then the point I wanted
to make the first point of information
is about solar panels I can testify that
they are they have increased in uh price
recently because I um have just bought
some and they are more expensive than
they were going to be
um and the second one
can I can I finish because I'm giving
you another point of information on
solar panels
um that we all agree that we would like
more solar panels on houses I just think
they all should be in the same way as
they have them in Sweden but the real
sticking point on this is building
control once we actually get some
changes to the building control
regulations and that then feeds through
to planning that will make it a lot
easier so I can assure you that I Lobby
wholeheartedly on such a matter finally
um these
these items in the Amendments I hate to
be so boring is to say yes they could
have gone through the climate change
panel but the point of the climate
change panel is it answers to osc and I
just have a funny feeling that you
didn't that whoever wanted to put these
through wanted to slip them through
rather than being them being scrutinized
by overview and scrutiny
thank you councilor councilorov
uh thank you chair
um it's not over 65's parking it's over
66.
because you're now pensioner at 66 not
65.
um and it's not Stratford upon
avon-centric
uh it's a residence in shixton
wellsbourne
um
Ulster driving into Stratford I want to
use Stratford as the main town
to uh socialize and shopping
um it's a scheme that can be self-funded
we're not asking for free parking
uh all day like it was before we've
never ever said that I came up with many
many
um scenarios and proposals and it can be
done it can be done for a bit more money
and for Less hours of parking and it can
be done and it can be self-funded and it
can be looked at and I'm actually quite
sad that it's not looked at because it's
nothing to do with just people that live
in Stratford upon Avon and also
it's about uh enhancing the viability of
our town lots of people do use Stratford
upon Avon to shopping and to socialize
in and to eat out in and to use the
theater
and it's and it's money into our town
and it's economic viability into our
town
um and and what what you're doing is you
are you are really increasing social
isolation I know so many people it's
still a very very
um Hot Topic I know so many people that
contact me and beg me to ask this
Council to bring it back again we don't
want it all day every day 24 hours a day
we want a sensible amount of hours maybe
four hours maximum
um so um yeah thank you thank you
Council
a genuine point of order
uh
I was seized by um councilor crump's
reference to those of us that are over
66 uh should I be declaring interest
because regrettably I have taken it as a
block I've taken on block that it
affects a number of counselors not all I
Hastings doesn't include yourself it
certainly does thank you very much for
that it doesn't get you an extra vote
I'm afraid
but thank you very much indeed cancer
right um
we are now at the end of the debate on
the amendment and thank you very much
indeed some very interesting stuff there
look I I'm going to ask can we take this
on block please
cancer unit the four items on block
could you
Amendment correct this
is being taken four items on the men on
there I would like to take them on block
if I may thank you very much indeed so
members this is a recorded vote we have
had the proposer we have had a seconder
uh we will now be going to the vote
councilor councilor promoted you that uh
Mr Buckland will now uh read out your
names and if you would respond
positively and clearly to the request
for your name please thank you thank you
chairman thank you Council so as was
explained on all the budget items this
afternoon we have to make recorded votes
we're now voting in relation to the four
items on the lib Dem Amendment which was
each one at a time as to whether you're
for against or abstaining in relation to
those amendments I will start with
chairman of the council councilor
Cargill against
thank you councilor Foreman
against
thank you councilor Adam
for
eign against
thank you councilor Bromwich against
the clevey's absent councilor Crump
against thank you councilor Curtis four
thank you councilor Dixon against
thank you councilor Eden four
thank you councilor Fielding against
thank you councilor fitter is absent
councilor Fleming
thank you councilor fortick
four
thank you counselor Ian friendly four
thank you councilor Jenny frenchly
I think you councilor Harris's absent
councilor Harvey
thank you counselor seraphin
thank you councilor Jefferson against
thank you councilor Genesis absence
councilor junid
four thank you counselor Kendall against
thank you counselor kettle
get
thank you counselor Mills against
thank you counselor O'Donnell against
thank you councilor Parry is absent
counselor Pemberton
against
thank you councilor portugala four thank
you
um councilor Richard councilor Riley
four
thank you councilor Rock
four thank you councilor Rolf
thank you councilor shenton
against councilor Wally Huggins
against thank you
yeah chairman number 12 votes four and
17 votes against therefore the amendment
is lost thank you thank you we now
return to the uh
I should ask are there any more
amendments
good thank you very much indeed all
right let's move to the main the
substantive motion now please uh
so we have had a proposal we have a
second to say I asked for any items of
anyone to debate on it please thank you
Council Rock and councilor Eden
chairman um I just I wanted to refer
members to page 27. uh and um the
comments reported uh attributed to
councilor Barker
um
in respect of
um the difficulties people with medical
conditions have with the waste uh
councilor Barker seems to be referring
to a very close definition of medical
waste in that the NHS can deal with that
I just wanted to
report
what I had when I raised this now I
raised this with
councilor shenton and with councilor
Fleming and I received very positive
responses about could we deal with some
method of dealing with it and I thank
them for that also from the leader but I
just wanted to tell you what a resident
said to me when the 123 collection
she'd got bowel cancer she's she said I
didn't want it I've got it I hate it but
I now have a stoma and I've now had
humiliation added to that by having to
deal with excessive quantities of the
appliances that she's got to dispose of
afterwards and surely the council could
do something about it and as I said
initially that was I had a very positive
conversation about Ian shenton I do ask
the cabinet to have a look at this uh in
the future I'm sure we've got some
method to deal with it uh I know that um
uh councilor Barker I'm sure is it it's
correcting what she says in an absolute
close definition of medical waste but we
are not all the discussions we've had
before that close definition we know
we're not what we're talking about just
to clarify that we're talking about
things that are appliances and all the
rest of it we're not talking about
Sharps and contaminated blood and all
the rest of it let's just let's all work
together do it and I know the members
are concerned about that the paper that
I wrote indicates that probably it's
it's a small number looking on National
figures and the analysis that I did
shows it's about only 30 people in each
Council Ward and I'm sure we can look at
something doing that in the future thank
you chairman thank you very much Council
Rock
um Council Adam
thanks German um I'd just like to say
that I actually welcome the um the
inclusion of uh the additional funding
for enforcement this is something that I
know many counselors um have had trouble
with
um across the district
um I have an ongoing case which I won't
mention the name of but has been going
on a long time simply because the the
resource that we've had in enforcement
has not been able to deal with it until
now uh in addition to the process so
this is a welcomed addition and
inclusion uh and although I won't be
able to support the budget as Pros as
the amendment fell I still do welcome it
and I want that to be noted that working
together clearly has resulted in some
good benefits here thank you
thank you very much indeed and I think
that this council's noted for as well uh
councilor Barker
um thank you yeah I just wanted to
clarify
um I've been having a a to and fro about
what is defined as what kind of device
the information I've always had is that
stoma bags grotty though it might be and
humiliating who it is and glad as I was
to dodge one when I had bowel cancer so
I do relate to this but they're not huge
yes there's quite a lot of them
um and they go in the normal gray bin
in the same way as
um adult nappies or any other items like
that and it simply is Sharps and if
there were blob products or if you were
having to have
um
changes of dressings big dressings
whatever they would have to go into the
medical ways rather than the gray waste
but that's the information I've had and
it can be wrapped and put in the gray
bin if they need another great bin they
can have another gray bin
thank you councilor Council Bromwich
yeah so does select councils know and
I've just looked this up actually so on
it's very up-to-date information one in
six councils are actually forecast next
12 months to be in financial trouble
we're lucky we're not in that position
but it does not but it does not mean say
we won't be if we act and decide to
spend the money too quickly
there will be consequences ultimately I
don't how many counselors are aware that
in the past few years there's been
forced Council mergers
not like we went through proper
consultations central government forces
local authorities together because they
simply didn't have any money anymore or
they were on Virtual bankruptcies
so whenever you are looking at this
medium term and it may look good now
we've got all these reserves and they do
believe I probably mentioned this about
five or six years ago
it is important we look after those
reserves and use any money from that to
be spent very wisely
it doesn't matter what political
persuasion you are
what you should remember whether it's
here today or campaigning into an
election in May is that your first
priority is to ensure that when it comes
to finances we remain financially sound
because how many of you really want to
be forced into a local Authority merger
without proper consultations without
proper public involvement where central
government tells you that's what you're
going to do how many of you here will
want has happened in Croydon central
government to say 15 council tax
increase because you were financially
irresponsible
so be careful when you start wanting to
spend the money in the shorter term
because as Council Jefferson pointed out
in the longer term
it may not look so Rosy let's be smart
on how we use money
let's today vote this through 3.2
percent is significantly less than
inflation
and over 10 less than our Parish
precepts in seldom
let us now turn around and accept the
fact we've got to be responsible for the
now for the next few years because I'm
going to tell you now central government
whether it's a conservative government a
labor government is not going to go
there suddenly chucking loads of money
local authorities I doubt they'll give
us long-term settlement we haven't had
it for a few years now and I don't think
it's going to happen for the next few
years
because of that it's important as
counselors we act in a responsible
Manner and try and minimize the impact
on our residents especially at the
moment when money is tight for a lot of
people
I will turn around say however I just
want to pay one little compliment that
is to the wonderful staff here at this
District Council because when people do
get in difficulties we're paying council
tax these staff are absolutely amazed at
helping them out extending terms
everything else and they should be fully
complemented
I think we all applaud that and thank
you very much indeed for that Council
Bromwich
uh interestingly just before Christmas
when we had a the old sound system we
couldn't I could never hear you now I
can too clearly sometimes but anyway
let's buy the bike
thank you very much indeed members um
Council project
thank you chair
um yeah I'll be supporting this uh
uh proposal for the revenue and capital
budget just purely because it'll be
irresponsible not to set a budget
um but going back to direction of travel
I think obviously there's an election
coming up in May
and it would be wonderful to have a
council that has a direction of travel
perhaps in competition with Orbit on
housing thank you
thank you uh Council unit
could I just ask as a request that we
asked for information to be gathered
over the next year unsuccessful schemes
for improved collection on medical and
other types of wastes to see if we can
become one of the best in class waste
collectors for this I know that there
are some Best in Class I'd like to learn
some lessons from them thank you thank
you councilor councilor Donald
thank you chair um it is actually just
to pick up on again on the
um increased black bin waste that people
with the incontinence has adult nappies
catter bags Etc are experiencing to
thank councilor Barker for the ongoing
dialogue we're actually having around
this
um with hopefully that the people we do
and it's a small number and thank you
counselor up for the amount of work
you've done around this because people
are embarrassed to discuss it but with
the drive to have people staying within
their homes especially further into
their lives you don't want them to be
embarrassed about asking for a black
then have to pay for so I thank
you for the open dialogue we're having
about it I think we're going to look for
some for some good news announcements
regarding this because as you say it's a
small number of people and we want
people to age with dignity in their
homes and not to be embarrassed to
discuss or to be discriminated from a
financial perspective because they need
an extra bin so thank you for that
thank you Council
right I don't see any more hands up to
discuss this item we have a proposer and
a seconder we can now move to the vote
which will begin recorded So recommended
to council that the proposed medium-term
Capital program detailed and appendix 4
to the Agenda Report or a suitable
Amanda burden which won't happen to be
agreed
that the proposed medium-term Revenue
budget detailed ad revised appendix 6 to
the Agenda Report supplementary or a
suitable amended version be approved and
that the level of council tax be set at
159 pounds 12 Pence for a bandee
property for 2023-2024
I'm sorry we've uh this is a point of
order
oh you're voting for it
I'm just going to make it clear that as
as a liberal Democrat group we have we
take it we do not use a whip and people
will be taking different decisions but
we want to make it clear very very clear
that there are some things on this
budget that we absolutely support and
that is cost of living and the energy
crisis measures we support thank you
very much indeed for that councilor
right can I move to the vote then Mr
Brooklyn thank you chairman uh
Chairman's written read out the three
recommendations of the page
27th this time I'll be asking whether
you're full against or abstain in
relation to those three recommendations
I'll start with councilor cargo or uh
councilor Foreman
four okay councilor Adam against
thank you councilor Barker for
eign
Curtis against
thank you councilor Dixon for
eign against
councilor Fielding four
thank you councilor uh councilor Fleming
four
thank you Council avoidik for
eign against
thank you councilor Jenny frenchly
thank you councilor Harvey
councilor Henderson sorry
thank you uh councilor Jefferson
four
thank you councilor Junaid
hence
thank you counselor Kendall for
thank you counselor Kettle Paul thank
you councilor Mills four
four
thank you councilor Pemberton four
thank you against
thank you councilor Riley
four
thank you Kessler Rock Against
thank you counselor wolf
thank you councilor shenton
four thank you councilor wooly hoggins
four thank you
coming at 19-4 and 10 against so the
chairman that was 19 votes four and ten
against and therefore the budget has
been approved thank you thank you very
much indeed and congratulations Council
because it's a very very important thing
to get our budget through thank you all
for that I'm now going to make uh take a
five minute break uh Comfort break so I
can see you back here by well four
o'clock thank you very much indeed
right thank you members
no no no no council tax 40.
thank you members right let's move on to
item 12 minute fives eight zero treasury
management strategy statement 30 23 24
and annual investment strategy uh
councilor Harvey
thank you Mr chairman
uh there's an annual requirement under
the guidance issued by the department
for leveling up housing and communities
for councils to draw up and approve an
annual investment strategy that meets
the chartered Institute of Public
Finance and accountancies treasury
management code of practice
the council's proposed treasury
management scheme for the fourth coming
year is set out on pages 73 to 101 that
comprise appendix one of the paper
considered by the cabinet at its
extraordinary meeting on the 13th of
February
at our corresponding meeting last year
on the 7th of February 2022 I drew the
cabinet's attention to the fact that at
that time the hot the bank of England
had just increased its base rate for the
second consecutive month to 0.5 percent
the first time increases have been
announced in consecutive months since
2004.
since then we've seen eight further
increases the most recent being
announced on the 1st of February so that
bank rate now stands at four percent
on the one hand this demonstrates the
degree to which the bank is serious
about its policy objective to control
inflation
this has consequence for borrowing costs
of both individuals and those of the
government itself on the other hand as
far as the council's finances are
concerned there's the prospect of a
continuation in the rate of investment
returns as were generated in 2022
for how long is a matter of conjecture
as section 2.3 on page 84 of the paper
considered by the cabinet outlined the
prospects are that during the next
financial year it's anticipated the
interest rates will decline although by
how much and on what timetable remains a
matter of speculation
the proposed capital and investment
strategy for the period 23 24 to 2728
was set out in appendix 2 on pages 103
to 116 of the papers also considered on
the 13th of February that proposal
provided the framework within which it's
intended the council should make its
capital and investment decisions over
the next five years
on the assumption that counselors have
been able to familiarize themselves with
these papers and subject to any
questions they may have I ask that
approval is given to recommendations one
to four as set out on page 30 in the
paper now before Council thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much do I have a
second for this Council Jefferson
Council two notice
and can I just make the um you know the
the points that um the ongoing impact on
the UK from the war in Ukraine and
higher inflation higher interest rates
and deteriorating economic Outlook are
on have to be major influences on this
Authority's treasury management strategy
for the year ahead but there's one other
thing that I want to make a point of and
that is the uncertain government policy
that has to be make mechanisms and there
has to be representations made from this
Council as backing the local government
Association councilor Jamison's Point uh
that he made at the local government
Association that there has to be more
certain government policy this has to be
a unified message that goes to
government that the local councils are
to be trusted and local governments
should be given certainty in their um
the money that comes from government in
the years ahead we cannot go on for the
one year on type strategies forevermore
thank you
thank you I don't think anyone would
vote against that
thank you very much indeed are there any
other speakers
in which case then
[Music]
um
on this one
well we agreed members the the on item
30 which is the items one to four I
won't read them out now oh we all agreed
thank you
item 13 Prudential indicators Council
Harvey
getting boring isn't it
thank you Mr chairman
um in conjunction with considering its
budget for the fourth coming year the
council is required by the chartered
Institute of Public Finance and
accountancy's Prudential code to set the
Prudential indicators that ensure that
its capital investment plans are
affordable prudent and sustainable
the report considered by the cabinet on
the 13th of February took account of the
council's decision to borrow up to 15.9
million pounds to support the delivery
of the current capital program
the paper considered at that meeting set
out the factors that the council through
its section 151 officer is required to
take into account when considering the
affordability in its particular
circumstances of its intended capital
expenditure over the period of the
medium-term financial strategy and the
affordability of the capital financing
requirement to which this intended
expenditure may give rise counselors
will have noted the intention to incur
capital expenditure in relation to the
materials recycling facility the council
share of expenditure as a result of the
refuse collection contract and in
relation to the facilities of the of the
district's Leisure centers with the
relevant amounts being set out in
paragraphs 1.5 to 1.7 of the paper
considered on the 13th of February
the section 151 officer is able to
confirm that he continues to be
satisfied that the requirements of
paragraphs 1.12 of the paper considered
by the cabinet on the 13th of February
which identified the indicators to which
the council is required to have regard
would continue to be observed and met
councilors are asked therefore to
approve the recommendation set out in
the paper that the proposed Prudential
indicators for the forthcoming year be
approved thank you Mr chairman
thank you Council Harvey do I have a
second for that
Council shenton thank you very much
indeed are there any speakers on this
item
may I then ask are we all agreed on this
great thank you
item 14 is the council tax for years
2023 to 24.
um I need to inform the meeting that in
accordance with the local Authority
standing orders England Amendment
regulation 2014 a recorded vote will be
taken on the council tax for 23.24.
Council Jefferson would you like to
introduce this item
thank you chair
this is a very simple item it's to
approve the formal council tax
resolution that's contain Independence a
I should just mention that if we do not
pass this then the bills for council tax
cannot be printed and we cannot collect
the council tax so it is rather
important at the moment that we approve
this so with that uh
I propose we approve the formal council
tax resolution appendix one of item 14.
thank you council do I have a second for
that please Council Pemberton
I'm sorry Mr Harvey Castle have you been
getting quick enough
okay right
um
are there any speakers on this item
that's a resounding no all right let's
go to the recorded vote please thank you
chairman
um so I'm again going to be recording
your name if you could please indicate
whether you're fought against or
abstaining in relation to the
recommendation which is on the separate
sheets item 14 which has been
distributed this afternoon
um councilor Cargill poor four
I think you can add them four
thank you councilor Barker for
thank you councilor Bromwich for thank
you councilor Crump for thank you
councilor Curtis
cue councilor Dixon for
thank you Kessler Eden for thank you
counselor Fielding thank you uh
councilor Fleming four
foreign
Jefferson four thank you councilor
Junaid oh thank you for
eign
thank you councilor Pemberton
four okay
thank you councilor Riley whoa thank you
councilor Rock four thank you councilor
wolf
four
thank you councilor shenton four thank
you councilor wooly hoggins
four
thank you I make that chairman 29 votes
four with no against and therefore carry
thank you thank you very much thank you
Council
right so let's move on to item 15 minute
513 notion of motion of motion motion uh
notice of motion a cost of living crisis
and I have councilor Barker who is going
to
um
announce this one thank you
I don't really want to throw it could
you take it
sorry we were just doing health and
well-being here of councilor Roth
apparently they're very tasty these ones
yeah
sorry sorry for the chaos as ever around
me
um we um
gosh I'm too loud on here as well I
apologize
we debated uh this notice of motion at
cabinet and accepted minute 513 in its
entirety save four
let me find the appropriate page
sorry I was discombobulated by the
sweeties there we are
um
so we considered the notification
and we accepted save for the requests
that the leader write to relevant
government ministers and local MPS
um
and basically that was the end of it
because it was a genuinely very good
idea with which we agreed and which
actually we superseded with some of the
monies that we awarded which we've
already discussed and I'm not going to
go into it again thank you
thank you
um
I I will ask for a second or on that one
if I may please
Council Pemberton thank you very much
first councilor put together
and then casserole yeah thank you chair
um
the liberal Democrat motion on the cost
of living a crisis asking for support
for our district residences being
recommended to council
the support for our residence is
important and urgent as I said in my
motion people living in rural areas like
cars besides having to cope with price
in hikes on energy and food are
disproportionately affected by fuel
prices increases because of the lack of
regular and interlinked public transport
and longer distances to reach work
education and Health Services
I want to thank the officers again for
the additional work already been done to
support residents from processing the
150 pounds council tax rebates promptly
to homelessness prevention work
to sign posting residents to benefits
and other support
the only thing that the cabinet has
rejected as councilor Curtis has already
referenced earlier in his speech is to
write to the ministers and rmps asking
for actions through the delivery of a
real increase in investment in UK
Renewables and developing a green energy
plan for the UK crisis it's
disappointing therefore that this has
been taken out of the motion and I don't
understand why this Council should not
write to our local conservative MPS
after all are best placed
to raise these in Parliament and with
the government
thank you kasarov
thank you chair
I believe we haven't reached the
magnitude of the real cost of living
crisis
um and that we're almost at the
beginning
um so I do hope that this Council would
give support to the residents where it's
most needed
um I agree it's a huge pity
that you're not writing to the
government on our resident's behalf
um why not uh what have you got to lose
I really do think you should have done
that thank you
thank you
um no more speakers
therefore
we've moved to the vote thank you very
much indeed
um do I have agreement to the Council on
this item agreed thank you very much
excellent
our next item item 16 minute
154 notice motion cutting of Highway
verges and cancellation oh sorry Fleming
is going to be presenting this one
I won't read through all of this but I'm
sure everyone's read their read their
papers and what was decided
um
a meeting of the cabinet was held on the
16th of January this year which the
following item had been just considered
and referred to cancer for determination
um we've met with with Warwick for
Warwick County Council who we cut on on
instruction from and uh
I'd like to go forward with the
the recommendation that's already on
page
page 36 and recommend to the council
that the new Warwickshire County Council
Highway word management policy will be
implemented as part of Stratford and
Avon District council's new grand
maintenance contract
and that the notice of motion be
accepted as detailed in recommendation
one as above
thank you
thank you do I have a second for that
Council shantam
uh I don't see any hands up oh sorry
counselor I do apologize I actually
wrote your name down as well I forgot I
apologize up to you
thank you Mr Jim
um I'm delighted that this is being
recommended for acceptance
it should offer us a tangible benefit to
biodiversity overall and add to some
weight to the climate change emergency
as well as offering us some eventual
maintenance cost benefits perhaps in the
future
um it's also good that in the interest
of the planet we can all work together
on both sides of the chamber so that's
good to see and thank you and
um I hope you'll all accept this
recommendation
well in that case then may I ask
council's agreement on this
thank you very much indeed Council
Fleming could you turn your microphone
off please
moving swiftly on member development
working group incentives to undertake
member training councilor Kettle is
going to present
thank you Mr chairman
um training is a critical part of our
responsibility to deliver the services
we should deliver as elected members of
this Council
um
the the
Democratic Services team in general
provide a wide range of courses
to cover a lot of different issues from
planning through to many other areas
which we can support the residents of
this District so the members Development
Group working group really takes
training incredibly important
importantly
um it isn't always easy to attend
training and also in the past uh kovid
has made training some more challenging
but we'll pass that now so I commend
these small changes
um
to the way we people approach training
as elected members
um I'm not going to carry on any more
about this but I commend
um
the recommendations to council
thank you do I have a secondary on that
may I have a second Council Mills thank
you Council Rock
thank you chairman I'd like to propose
an amendment to the wording of um number
one and I think there's a slip of paper
that officers have got with the wording
on it
uh which is being passed around now like
hymn books as a service
um
I I'll read those out in advance of the
distribution
um yes please I'm going to do that but
yes please do Council encourages each
member to Monitor and achieve the
minimum number of their training hours
each year
prioritizing their training for subjects
appropriate to their own requirements
this is intended to be a friendly
amendment that is just to do with how we
implement the um
the concept behind the whole
recommendation here which we all support
uh certainly on my side
um
hopefully this re this wording will uh
support and encourage appropriate
knowledge uh not just on numbers but uh
on the character of the training so you
know I wouldn't suppose that uh cancer
Crump or other Chartered Accountants in
the room need training on there
uh qualifications I
I nobody needs to declare an interest
um and uh
it covers I think various things I think
it's an improvement uh and uh it's a
question of self-discipline rather than
being told what to do for elected
members so I look for a second counselor
kettle
cancer Kettle secondary thank you I'm
happy to accept this amendment and uh
two second Council launch proposal in
that case then thank you very much any
other speakers cancer Jr I'm just
wondering to what extent when counselors
undertake professional treatment
training that is appropriate
that can be taken on board by the
council in liaison with the officers to
decide whether that is appropriate or
not that's correct
awesome
sorry uh yes I should just check Council
Mills as you seconded are you happy with
the amendment
yes Miss German I think uh Council for
Jake
and then Council board
yeah just um a clarification uh where it
sort of says Council encourages each
member to monitor rather than each group
leader that's probably more relevant as
well to Independent members such as
myself
and does that
um then Place more responsibility on
sort of communication between members
and officers to achieve that
thank you councilor Bromwich then
Council Harvey yeah just to confirm I
actually do know that the council do
take on board trading from outside their
own training because actually I've
undertaken some over many years whether
it's been visits to the houses upon but
public finances or major safeguards up
at Manchester and that so
I'll say Democratic Services always been
supportive of relative training outside
of the training we provide in-house
thank you Council Harvey
thank you Mr chairman I am a member of
this the
member Development Group and this is a
thorny problem
um while I I don't object to this
proposed amendment
um I think it begs as many questions as
IT addresses because what is appropriate
to one counselor may not be appropriate
to another which is as you would expect
but just as uh councilor Rock mentioned
that certain professionally qualified
accountants may not feel the need to go
to a finance session at one sort or
another they might and I think this
boils down to
um
ensuring that members are suitably
educated trained and knowledgeable in
order to discharge their function as
representative of their residence and to
deal with technical issues that they get
involved with it depending on which
which bodies they sit on is a personal
responsibility this comes down to the
quality and the the experience and the
initiative and the degree of
responsibility of individual members of
this Council and while I don't object to
these words in this this amendment it
doesn't detract from the individual
members responsibility in the vernacular
to get their finger out
thank you for that uh Council Harvey uh
yes I do sit on that can uh that
committee as well and I've got to say it
is a thorny problem and I think this is
a good Amendment uh Council body hoggins
that we need to place a great deal of
emphasis on training coming to the end
of this cycle of election the end of our
four years because the the training
cycle starts again after the next set of
Elections and really it's about
empowering us to make the right
decisions for our residents if you
haven't been trained in it
um there are some uh quite a lot of
media videos at the moment about a
certain uh Farm shop at the moment
that's hitting there is but those what
I'm trying to say is at any time there
could be cameras and we're held with
count these these um Council meetings
are in the public domain to be
scrutinized you know members have to
remember that the training is so
important so that they're making
informed decisions about what lies
before them and actually anything that
encourages members to do the right
amount of training for those areas that
they are involved in making making
critical decisions so for licensing you
know these are businesses that that we
are making decisions about and we have
to give that the gravitas
that it requires really and that means
that we need to do adequate amount of
training in order to fulfill our role as
elected members of this Council so
anything that encourages that that
people do the right amount of training
for what they're responsible for can
only be a good thing thank you
thank you and I'm sure it's echoed
through the chamber members I'm sensing
that we are generally in agreement with
this can I ask for council's agreement
thank you very much indeed
the next item on the agenda is minute
576 pay policy statement 2023-24 annual
review Council Jefferson
thank you chair this is a routine report
produced every year I would draw members
attention to the final paragraph on page
40. which says the committee accepted
that the proposed payer policy statement
more than met the legal requirements of
the localism act and sought to achieve
best practice rather than just legal
compliance I think that is true I would
also just point out the issue in the
paragraph above
uh there are going to be issues with
recruitment there are issues of pay
within the sector there's absolutely no
doubt about that
um the human resources manager advised
the committee that paying rewards in
general
will be reviewed as part of the work to
develop the staff strategy which will
start imminently
so can I just say that the
recommendation that the pay policy
statement as appended to the Agenda
Report be adopted for the period 23 to
20 23 24 I propose we accept that chair
thank you do I have a second for that
are we all in agreement Council
thank you very much moving on
item 19 is a minute 578 Environmental
Health licensing restructure
and that is counselor kettle
thank you Mr chairman
um
this is really establishing well
where we are currently with the with the
licensing environmental team
um the one change that we're seeing is
that we will no longer be offering a
pest control service we have one pest
control officer
um and we've historically had two we
can't operate with one and therefore the
restructuring involves the loss of that
post the individual concerned uh will be
setting up his own business
um
when we originally managed Pest Control
across the district we were about the
only Pest Control Service uh residents
could go to Pest Control is now
delivered by significant numbers of
private sector organizations
and therefore the need for for this
Council to provide that service has
effectively become redundant and with
one employee it is very difficult to
continue to deliver
work District Council no longer has Pest
Control Service as do many other local
authorities no longer deliver pest
control so we're actually falling into
line with those other services uh
I'll say no more
thank you uh council do I have a second
to finish
councilworthy Hawkins
um councilor Junaid asked to speak
yes um I have some
unconcerned about it um because although
I recognize
that local authorities are not legally
required to provide a pest control
service
they do Under the prevention of damage
by pest act 1949 are required to take
such steps as may be necessary to secure
as far as is practicable that their
district is kept free of rusts and mice
urban sprawl
discarded litter
international travel
on the onset of climate change are all
factors caused by human behavior that
exposes increasingly to pests and pest
related diseases
and this is why I want it to be kept
under review
because all the more relaxed all the
most reliable evidence suggests that
numbers are increasing this is of rats
and Rises particularly in a urban areas
but it is beyond this that I'm could
have some concerns because the range of
organisms that are carried by rodents
and the severity of some of those
diseases that they cause
should be enough to demonstrate the
importance of making sure under that
1949 act that we are looking at
preventing rodents from entering areas
where people live work or play
and there are also other significant
economic factors to consider such as the
effects on degraded environments
certain insects also post ages flies and
cockroaches in particular can spread
numerous disease-coding bacteria viruses
and protozoa
and my concern is not for the now
my concern is for the future because
climate change will undoubtedly affect
the distribution and proliferation of
Inspector insects and the diseases they
carry and also the proliferation an
increase of rats and mises and the
diseases they follow
the 1949 Act was originally brought in
for a reason
and going back in history we know why
local councils were brought in to do the
pest control for a reason
I don't want us to get to a stage where
because the pest the private sector Pest
Control
becomes so expensive that we don't we
get people just deciding not to take
action because then we will go back in
history to 1949 or even back
to dare I say some of the
horrendous background that we had when
local councils first got involved in
this way back in the 18th century thank
you
thank you councilor Jenny frankly
councilor
so we've all got coughs this afternoon
thank you chair
um I'd like to endorse what councilor
junid has just said but also say that um
residents that I speak to have valued
this service hugely they have confidence
in it and they value it I'm very sad to
see that the environment service that we
offer or the environment
section of this operation is under such
pressures that it can't actually offer
this service anymore I know some time
ago it was a suggestion that the SDC
could have
um a commercial arm that would offer
this Pest Service to to Residents
because as I say it is so respected and
residents have confidence in it so I'd
very much support what councilor junit
has said to keep this under review
although it might be more work for
environment to keep it under review to
ensure that we don't actually
by mistake encourage infestations that
would do more damage thank you
thank you Council Curtis
thank you
um reiterating my two colleagues have
just said
um I think we should keep this under
review and I just wonder I noticed that
you say um says both Warwick and
noneetan and bedith Council have
withdrawn from delivering Pest Control I
wonder is there any data I don't know
when that was withdraw the service was
withdrawn
but has there been any data on whether
or not the levels of pest infestation
have increased as a result of that I
think that may be useful data for us to
be able to get from our neighboring
authorities thank you
thank you Council Harvey
thank you Mr chairman uh just trying to
keep us into proportion in this
discussion
um we're talking about the inability to
run in the effective service based upon
one individual whether we employed that
one individual and he was active or not
whether in the public sector or the
private sector I don't think it's going
to save us from plague plague of locusts
and rice and mice
um my my concern is uh simply that we
keep the matter in proportion and I'm
sure that whether it is uh pestilence
due to insects or rats and of mice I'm
sure that the Environmental Health
Service will have regard to their
statutory duties to keep residents safe
and if they want to come up with a
different suggestion at a different time
in different circumstances I'm sure
we'll all be quite willing to consider
it
thank you Council Pemberton
ah thank you uh chair um yeah councilor
Harvey's just made a point I was to make
around responsiveness to changes whether
they'd be driven by climate change or
anything else for that matter
um councilor fragile talked about
setting up a commercial arm frankly
that's exactly what the staff had done
and are about to do
um these are the people who've been
delivering this service and they're
going out and striking out on their own
because there's been a reduction in the
demand for the service so they're
setting themselves out and I think the
notion that in a competitive environment
price will be driven the other way I
think that doesn't generally uh that's
not generally how competitive markets
work and there's no indication of any
kind of Monopoly basis being created
that would would adversely impact on
that
there isn't resilience it's not a
statutory service and the number of
inquiries for the service are at a level
that would not justify it anyway it can
be something it's something that can be
delivered effectively by another organ
other than this organization if that
were to change councilor Harvey is
absolutely right I think all members
would support that but for now and here
um this is not something to continue
with
cancer Rock
uh thank you chairman
um I I think this is quite a difficult
area given that you know that we're only
talking about one person and the
difficulties and maintaining the service
I've got every sympathy as to the
thoughts that uh lie behind it
I'm slightly worried about the sort of
signals it sends in terms of protecting
the environment and our residents
uh
and I've just got a question
um we I think I'm right insane if if we
have I'm not quite sure the expectation
is but people trust the council
in respect of the environmental health
and I sit on the regulatory committee
and I'm very always very impressed uh by
the reports we've got I get from the
Environmental Health Service so I'm
fully in support of that
but that's a trusted service now my
understanding is the independent and I'm
not talking about any particular
individual that's that might be may or
may not believe in the council but this
is a non-regulated activity it's not
like taxes or something where where we
regulate that when we're talking about
going out to the private sector as I
understand it and I'll I would welcome
um clarification from the portfolio
holder but I think anybody can set
themselves up as a pest control uh
operative and in Vera the duty of care
that councilor junit has talked about
and I noticed that Phil Grafton was
nodding his head
um I'm slightly concerned that we're
putting it out to
a group of people that someone who I'm
sure are very good in the private sector
but others we don't know about and with
the council having a trusted
Environmental Health Service
I'm I am worried about the signals that
it's sending so uh I recognize the
difficulty but I just want to make sure
we've given that full thought so I've
got unease about the proposal thank you
chairman
thank you chairman um
I'll be supporting this this proposal
um but but I suppose a sort of we're
needing some clarification on whether
there's any collection of data that will
continue within the District Council of
some kind
regarding reporting of any kind of pest
infestations that do take place because
we probably do need to keep an eye on it
or become a an effective signposter
um
to um to inquiries on pest control
because we may still find people that
will come to the council too
report
um these kind of things and just to note
Birmingham city council do have a pest
control service
and in fact if you call them out for
rat Pest Control it's a free service
on that particular Point
um who made a couple of issues there Mr
Phil's going to have just respond on
that one thank you
yeah um so Castle tunic was referring
earlier to the 1948 49 Pest Control Act
that that's essentially the act under
which officers will inspect premises on
complaint so in terms of data
we presume that that data would be held
and would be available to make decisions
into the future about whether to adjust
the provisions that are now being
proposed
thank you uh cancer kettle
well if you
'd like to respond to some of the points
raised
the environmental health team is
responsible for public health in in the
district and that will not be changing
uh the environmental health officers are
responsible for their duties under
prevention of damage by pest by pest act
which you referred so those
responsibilities will still be
continuing
with the team led by Paul Reed
there is no suggestion that the district
council is going to walk away from those
responsibilities
um
it has been challenging to deliver
Pest Control in its very focused element
with one person
and as I think has already been said
there are now many organizations
delivering that service in the private
sector
we will be working as necessary if we
identify problems to ensure that public
health maintain is maintained at the top
of our agenda
it is purely about how
pest control and it's very focused
definition is delivered in this District
and the decisions have been taken that
with only one offset is far more
effective to allow the private sector to
deliver that clearly if there are issues
which are picked up by environmental
officers
then which have implications to which
you referred earlier on
then we'll be picking that up and
ensuring that your concerns are
addressed if and when something takes
place which needs to be dealt with under
the ACT
thank you
thank you members
um well Council primary Ian project
thank you chair as an example of rats in
particular I had an incident in my ward
a couple of months ago
where the the owners of the property
um had got rats inside their green caddy
um a couple of rats and I I after after
it had been emptied supposedly but it
seemed to me as if the caddy hadn't been
completely emptied
so that might have an impact on this
Council because a lot of the caddies
when they're thrown back
um they're not the lids are not always
shut
so rats could get into them
you might like to think dwell on that
one thank you very much
um members are we all in agreement on
this item
no we're not okay we'll go to a vote
then
so that's the recommendation right thank
you members the
recommendation we have a proposing a
second
uh the recommendation on page 41 is that
the provision of a directly provided
Pest Control service be ceased
all those in favor
right hold on
I'll hold your hands up
okay and all those against
any extensions
and so it is carried thank you very much
indeed
moving on
the item 20 is urgent report and these
are just for noting
they have been noted
right
um item 21 is the annual update I think
we've all seen those circulated to
everybody and that is for noting
item 22 counselor questions
now she'll run through these uh question
one Council Junior do you have a
supplementary question
could could the uh in response to
um the leader
um my question is that because if I
wanted to make a political Point quite
frankly I I could have done but I didn't
um could he check
because my data my data says that the
constituencies of conservative MPS
have actually received 46.7 of the funds
of the 25 bids awarded to local
authorities who were not in the most
deprived areas judged by the indices of
multiple deprivation 52 went to Kansas
councils run by conservatives and I
believe Richmond was one of these could
he possibly check those figures please I
will most certainly check those figures
counselor unit
um interestingly enough I happen to know
the area where the North Yorkshire bid
was it was catterick and that is
actually a seriously deprived area in
North Yorkshire
thank you uh Council Cox not here
Council junid on question three do you
have a supplementary
yes I do I wonder whether you could
possibly check
um some of the figures because these are
figures that have been reported to the
district council I understand but I was
in conversation with the managing
director Paul Richards of orbit and his
another one of his managing directors
this week and he gave figures that were
considerably more than the figures that
have been given here so it's obvious
that the figures that are being reported
to orbit are not being reported to the
district council and of those ones that
he he gave me the figures for
um they were of level one and level two
with a few in level three which are the
most serious categories for damp and
mold
uh so it does mean that we if we are not
working to full figures of what the
complaint levels are in this District
then we're not seeing the full extent of
the problem so could she please check
with orbit to make sure that we are
working to the most up-to-date numbers
of complaints made about damper mold
within this District thank you thank you
absolutely
thank you very much indeed uh cancer
Curtis do you have a supplementary
question thank you very much councilor
together do you have a supplementary
no I don't disappointing reply but I
don't
thank you very much uh Council Cleaver
is not with us cancer Adam do you have a
supplementary no thank you uh councilor
off do you have a supplementary
yes
uh yes I do
um yes thank you for your response um
as I chair the support group set up by
the Town Council and town Trust
we have a whole group of organizations
and Partnerships on that group
and we are looking at I am setting up
meetings with those Partnerships to look
at ways that we can help
those uh within the towns draft upon
Avon initially but we also have somebody
that is going to help us look at helping
people in the district as well
and you might want to I mean it's up to
you if you wish to know what we are
doing and what we're working on
um but we that's what we're planning to
do thank you
actually I'd be delighted to talk to you
about it when I was a kid
um
my mum and I during the school holidays
when schools weren't providing meals on
wheels which is how it used to happen
cooked meals in our own kitchen and put
them in a
charcoal heated oven to take ground to
our locality so it's something that's
kind of rather deeply embedded in me
doing Meals on Wheels so I do we're
sadly not going to be able to go back to
that which was quite fun but I'm very
very happy to talk to you about it
because I think it is something that we
need to address
thank you right uh count question nine
cancer Jenny frankly do you have a
supplementary
thank you very much uh question 10
councilor Curtis do you have a
supplementary
thank you Jeff I just this has been such
an ongoing I'm sorry customer an ongoing
saga we're now being asked to comment on
the on the local plan
obviously there are connections do you
have any further date as to when this
study might be completed
other than later in the year
I wish
I I mean to be fair
um so it's ourselves Holmes England and
Warwickshire County Council and I think
councilor Curtis
um from our own discussions will know
that I am looking for us to move at as
much Pace as possible
to provide Clarity around the future uh
as far as the uh
longmaster Airfield and obviously the
concurrent impacts on Southwest relief
Road I absolutely understand uh you know
particularly you know the the the
position that residents on Ludington
Road find themselves in and I can only
assure councilor Curtis and other
members of this Authority that I am
pushing as hard as I possibly can
because I want to see progress on this
as much as he does and as much as the
residents for Ludington turn but I'm
probably still at the very first answer
I gave
thank you uh final question Council
Ralph do you have a Super 8 no thank you
very much indeed excellent uh okay let
us move now on to item 23 which is
questions to the leader Council Junaid
Council clear together Council
um with the introduction of voter ID
postal votes are likely to become a much
more prevalent as a means to vote could
the leader confirm that an instructions
have been given to councilors all
counselors and potential candidates and
to canvases and all involved in this
election uh that postal vote forms are
to be delivered directly to Elizabeth
house that they are not to be involved
in the return of postal votes and it can
he confirm that this is covered by the
relevant code of conduct
that is something I'll have to get back
to you on camera counselor unit I want
to make sure I've got it absolutely
right
thank you uh because
um the Alternative Energy bills support
Grant for Park Homes residence as well
as many other types of
homes was delayed to the end of February
very few details have been given from
government to officers on the
administration of such scheme there is
now a live application process via the
government portal which means many
elderly and vulnerable residents will
miss out if they do not apply it takes
at least six weeks to process which
means those residents who are able to
successfully apply will have to wait
until at least April to get the 400
pounds the government had the chance to
plan it and pilot it since last summer
will the leader join me in saying how
shambolic this government scheme has
been and now unfair its rollout has been
for hundreds of our district residents
I don't know enough to comment but off
the top the answer is no
thank you Council for chick
just one question for the leader
um obviously coming up in the next few
weeks and months are going to be Road
works on the Birmingham Road
and that's going to lead to some
significant disruption and impacts
um
so really it's really to to ask the
leader to make sure that Ward members
such as myself and surrounding Ward
members and perhaps all members in in
Stratford get regular updates from the
County Council so that we are fully
versed with what's going to happen next
thank you councilor foruchek
as I live about a hundred yards away
from Birmingham Road I am fully in
agreement with what you're saying
thank you Castleford
future
would the leader give an update on the
world-class material
ity that we are currently building with
partner authorities and the benefits to
the council taxpayer and to the climate
and would he agree that it is due to
this conservative administration's
foresight and Ambitions that everyone
will benefit
thank you
the material to recycling facility is
indeed state of the art there's
absolutely no doubt about that
the investment the district is making in
that is around about 9 million
we are one of the Consortium of eight
councils
developing that
because it is dear to the art it will
enable much greater sorting of the
recycler
that actually means that we will
probably get more for the recycling than
we would in more conventional materials
recycling facilities
that should probably give us a much
greater return than we anticipated in
financial terms
because the price that we get for the
recycling will offset the gate fee it
also means it will be an awful lot
better for the environment boot costs
far more will actually be recycled
thank you Council Dixon
hey chairman
um
the 123 system has been mentioned a few
times this afternoon already and
obviously it's been running now for a
while
but what we haven't had is a note of
what the recycling rates are and I just
wondered if you have the numbers
available to us this afternoon
obviously it's a very uh system which
the liberal Dems did fail to actually
vote and agree when it went through the
conservative like party Etc
um what other uh yeah I'll leave it at
that yeah what are the what are the
rates we're doing
thank you at the moment the rates are in
the order of 60
and we are ninth I believe nationally
uh the rate should actually improve and
we should be in the top ten
within the very near future
thank you Council Mills
thanks Mr chairman we've talked uh a lot
about economics today
has warned that the UK risks falling
behind Eastern European nations in
economic terms
what are the leaders views on this and
what can we do to change this
thank you
thank you councilor Mills
uh
it's actually quite refreshing
that labors finally realized just how
significant economic growth is
uh
the lib Dems I think have yet to catch
up with that
on current trends what he says he's
actually quite possible
our economic performance at the moment
is the worst it's been for 200 years
and the underperformance we've got
recently started in 2007.
it is not directly the result of the
conservative government it started in
2007.
it's also not directly the result of
brexit
because like I say starting in 2007 a
brexit did not happen until about 2020.
so people keep saying these things
frankly they're talking rubbish but it's
convenient for them to see it
if we really are going to focus on
economic growth it's going to require an
awful lot of Shifting attitudes
it's got to be top of the agenda
end of story
it means an awful lot more support for
business it means an awful lot more
support for investment
and that could well
not go down well with an awful lot of
members of the labor party I do
sometimes wonder where the sake of
starmer could find himself in a similar
position to all love Sean's
thank you very much indeed leader are
you finished on that particular item uh
I will all right can we just keep it to
District matters please apart from
geopolitical uh very interesting I'm
sure but uh let's just stick to the
district the things that are back and
I'm not saying that these won't
ultimately impact the district but let's
stick to the district today please okay
then uh next is Council Junaid your
second yes when the leader confirmed
that I actually supported
recycling facility going forward as
somebody who has worked extensively in
this field of waste and recycling I I
supported it and and had there was no
problem with that at all so it was
cross-party support and can the leader
also to also um support that in the the
latest official figures that are around
uh Stratford District Council was not in
the top ten I hope it will be but the
top number top was sent albums it was
64.2 percent set South Oxfordshire was
second was 63.6 Three Rivers was third
with 63.1 percent I would hope that we
would like to be and we'll hope that we
are in the top uh the top um percentage
of recycling figures the material
recycling
facility is not one particular party so
a question please it was across
Partnerships all the councils that have
agreed together to do this is there a
question Council and don't make it a
political issue please was there a
question there
oh
it's the leader could you confirm that I
also supported the material recycling
facility and that these are the figures
the latest figures for 2020 2021 that
exists councilor June and I'm not aware
that I said you didn't
no it was on the one two three worst
collection center uh where's collection
service where liberal Democrats did not
support okay right I think I can move on
please Council courtesy your next
question please thanks yeah I will stick
to the point
regarding the 123 plus waste collection
we are I think somewhat seduced
am I getting a question yes there will
be a question really there will be a
question okay absolutely I think we're
somewhat seduced by the amount of
recycle it that is being collected and
the ever increasing amounts of recycling
I want to see recycling reduced
so my question to the leader is what is
he going to do with this Council to
encourage residents to reduce and reuse
and hence reduce recycling I think we
need just need to be careful not to be
seduced by the wrong outcome so my
question what can we do or what will the
leader do to encourage reduced reduction
and reuse thank you Jay
um can I just say that uh in reality
taking waste away from being from going
to landfill and having it recycled is a
step in the right direction reducing
recycling actually requires far more
than the council doing things it
requires an awful lot of the
manufacturers and packages to do things
so it's not just one person that needs
to do it and one organization that just
needs to do it it needs a system-wide
view but at the moment if I look at the
waste I put in the non-recycling it is
down massively on where it was a year
ago if I look at what I put in the food
caddy for recycling the food which can
actually be used to generate energy that
is really useful and you look at the
impact that he's having on reducing food
waste it is actually quite tremendous so
the benefits from the 123 system frankly
are huge
thank you very much indeed uh Council
Pemberton
thank you chairman um
two quick observations I think the we
all agree about the ReUse yeah that what
I was going to say that comes under
dragging people kicking and screaming to
change
um
and being at the front of a partnership
unlike Warwick District who were dragged
Kicking and Screaming to joining the
murf shows leadership but talking about
the economy and stuff that we can
actually do about the economy
um could the leader share with us what
he sees as the benefits of
a striving and delivering the driving
Innovation growth
seminar and where he sees that taking
our economy and partnership particularly
with the university and the Growth
Company
thank you councilor Pemberton A really
excellent question
uh
that is an awful lot we can do locally
The Innovation and growth seminar was a
start
we've worked very closely with the
University of Warwick we've worked very
closely with the growth hope
the event that was held a week on Friday
actually threw up an awful lot of
interested issues
I did mention scale up
uh when we follow up
on that
event
that is probably going to be the first
particular issue we look at because
there is an awful lot that can be done
locally and there is an awful lot we
need to do locally
you put together the
development that we intend taking place
on the Airfield and the development of
the campus and we can reposition an
awful lot of the industry and employment
in the district and to be honest that's
the intention we'll continue to work
closely with the university we'll
continue to work closely with the growth
hope
and as we develop the local plan and the
economic strategy we will bring the
Growth Company the West Midlands
combined Authority Growth Company on
board so there's a whole raft of things
we can actually do to drive our local
economy
uh rather than just always rely on
central government
thank you Council Ian fratley
thank you chair
as you may be aware there's been a
dramatic increase in nighttime crime
particularly International Haven on the
9th of February the herald called for
the police the County Council and the
district council to come together to
discuss what could be done regarding
security and safety
of residents and their properties
please could you tell me what progress
has been made in setting up these
discussions
frankly counselor frankly I'm not aware
of any I've seen no initiatives from the
police and certainly none from the
County Council but it is something that
I will take up because I have been
discussing with the chief executive
about having a meeting with the chief
Constable given the spirit of car thefts
there were very recently uh it does seem
as though those are meetings which used
to be held regularly need to be restored
to a greater frequency because I've had
comments from residents about crime in
Stratford and the car thefts have not
been a good experience for many people
who felt really really threatened there
is no doubt about it something really
does need to be done
for the district council is only one
player in that
thank you final question is counselor
kettle
uh thank you Mr chairman
um we regrettably see uh on Wednesday
the departure of one of our senior
Democratic service officers
will uh the leader support me in
thanking not only that parting member of
democratic Services who's sitting at the
foreign of the room
um
but but also all Democratic Services
team they're not
um highly lauded because all they do is
make sure that we get meetings on time
with the right papers and we make the
right decisions without their support
life for members would be very very much
more challenging so to thank all members
of democratic Services team but also
specifically on this occasion to thank
this divorceka farha services to this
Council before she departs actually
temporally to go to supporting the voter
ID and and the elections and so she
won't be disappearing immediately but
there will be time when she's not with
us anymore and I'd hope you don't
support me on that
I would fully endorse what you said
Council
[Applause]
I have to say that the Democratic
Services team do a really amazing job
for us
thanks very much indeed uh okay members
thank you very much indeed for those
questions uh I'm now moving on to item
24 which is motion of uh notice of
motion keep saying that Housing
Association for information only uh
urgent business I am not aware of any so
I'd just like to thank you all members
because it's been a very intense debate
today in some uh some areas thank you
for Barrett and I really appreciate it
because you made my life